so now so let's talk about the problem
of life then the origins of life
has to be a transition in which you use
which the living System is using this
process that's self-destructed
to keep the self-destructive processes
from being self-destructive
but it has to use them to do this how is
that even possible
okay I just finished editing this
podcast this is one of the most deep
technical talks the first 20 minutes are
difficult to follow and you may wonder
where is it going and how is it related
to the topic at hand what you'll notice
that by the end every tendril from every
argument gets tied together neatly and
nicely so look through the timestamps if
what you're interested in is specific
subjects or watch until the end all of
it where it plays out like a beautiful
Orchestra or movie where all the story
lines start to intersect toward the end
today we talk about Consciousness why
darwinian evolution is incomplete and
the symbolic grounding problem which is
another aspect of the hard problem of
Consciousness which I call the hard
problem of meaning Professor Terence
Deacon is a neuroanthropologist who's
taught at Harvard for eight years and is
currently a professor at the University
of California Berkeley he has an
extraordinarily philosophical mind he
has studied under Chomsky Noam Chomsky
even though he has major disagreements
with him and part of his aim is tackling
the evolution of human cognition as well
as the heart problem of Consciousness
which in his view is not so hard Terence
will be coming on again for a part two
so if you have questions then do leave
them in the comment section because I'll
be calling from there I or and my wife
read every single comment my name is
Kurt J mungle and I have a background in
mathematical physics mainly in the
theoretical end with unified theories
and this channel is dedicated to the
exploration of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from primarily a
physics perspective but as well as
exploring the role that Consciousness
has to the fundamental laws of nature
provided that those laws are even
knowable to us and if they're not
because of some variant of girdles and
completeness Theorem then why why does
that have any application to physics if
you're interested in hearing more
podcasts like this then do consider
going to patreon.com
or you can go to
theoriesofeverything.org and supporting
with a contribution of whatever you like
as the only reason that I'm able to do
this full time is because of the patrons
so the supporters like yourself as well
as the sponsors now speaking of sponsors
there are four there's rocket money
there's Masterworks there's brilliant
and there's Uncommon Goods the former
two rocket money and Masterworks you'll
hear it approximately 20 minutes and
then again at 40 minutes for roughly 60
seconds each and as for brilliant it's
also 60 seconds which is occurring
presently if you're familiar with toe
you're familiar with Brilliance but for
those who don't know Brilliance is a
place where you go to learn math science
and engineering through these bite-sized
Interactive Learning experiences for
example and I keep saying this I would
like to do a podcast on information
Theory particularly Chiara marleto which
is David Deutsch's student has a Theory
of Everything that she puts forward
called Constructor Theory which is
heavily contingent on information Theory
so I took their course on random
variable distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order thank you and
enjoy this highly anticipated and far
overdue conversation with Terence Deacon
Professor I'm super super excited to
have you on I feel like this is long
overdue the more that I've researched
you the more that I realized man this is
a guess that I should have had on a year
ago and I should have prepared for a
year and what I mean by that is I
prepare for gifts for weeks for most
people I come up with a question every
minute or so or every 30 seconds of
watching a lecture of theirs online and
maybe one question per paragraph if I'm
reading a paper whereas for you it's
fivefold so it's like questions occur so
much that I'm scrolling and then I told
you I couldn't collect them all into one
place so anyway thank you so much for
coming on
no problem I love I I love to have a
conversation so oh you know open
conversations like this are the best
so this channel is dedicated to
understanding fundamental reality
whatever that means so why don't you
give a brief overview of your insights
your research
with respect to that topic with respect
to Consciousness with respect to
the large questions that Loom over once
moments of existential dread so take us
through how your views have developed
over time where have they been and how
do they change so I'll do a sort of
autobiographical sense that in the 1970s
um as a student I was very much
interested in uh the burgeoning computer
science world uh in systems theory as a
general theory of how the world Works
How the Universe Works
um and uh was a a student of a student
of Gregory Bateson one of one of my uh
long-term influences over the years uh
who was
um a very eclectic Anthropologist and
biologist whose father
um William Bateson was sort of the the
father of genetics uh the beginning of
the 20th century and Gregory Bateson was
very much interested in information and
communication and it spent
um the 1940s and 50s associated with a
number of people were studying
um the then growing field of information
Theory communication Theory and systems
theory and as a result set me off but by
the end of the 1970s
I by accident mostly by accident not
being interested in philosophy at all
really I was mostly interested in the
Sciences
um came across the work as I say by I
accidentally almost a philosopher of the
late 19th century Charles Sandra's purse
and he was writing also about what today
we might call information and
communication but he had developed a
an unusual way of thinking about it that
basically had mostly fallen out of uh
the field of science and communication
and particularly out of linguistics uh
by the 1970s and it's a field that he
called semiotics
and as now since then has grown to be a
much more uh widespread field with lots
of interest
um though mostly in the humanities and
that's always Disturbed me because I
think it's really a fundamental approach
to The Sciences uh and that was person's
interest
um back when he was writing a semiotic
theory is basically uh like
a theory of information only bigger uh
in the following sense that he was
interested in uh what most theorists of
Mind have been interested before and
since and that is this question about
mental representation you know how are
things represented uh when something is
represented of course it's not there
it's something standing in forward in
some ways but it doesn't help us
understand what that actual physical
relationship is and one of the
Challenges ever since uh in philosophy
has been to try to make sense of that
person's way of approaching it was to
say no there's actually
um three different ways in which this is
done
um and he was right recognizing that
there are representations by likeness
iconic he called it
um representations by correlation or
contiguity or part whole relationships
causal relationships in some call some
form he called indexical relationships
another kind of relationships that words
for example have to what they represent
which is uh based on some kind of
agreement of how to interpret sounds but
there's nothing about the words we
produce in most cases
that is linked to what they represent
right we sometimes gloss this over by
saying it's arbitrary
um one thing that's happened in
linguistics and one of the things that
got me interested in language and the
origins of language was
um
why we're the only species that does
this we're the only species that does
this meaning does language does language
or in fact what I'll eventually say is
that does what we would call symbolic
communication that is something distinct
from Iconic and indexical communication
the question is
um for me at the time who became
interested eventually in the
neurosciences I spent I spent most of my
career as a neuroscientist uh studying
mostly development of brains and how
they've evolved and my original question
was well so what happened if language is
so unusual and it takes a very unusual
kind of cognition to accomplish it it
must have evolved at some point and
therefore there should be in effect a
reflection of this in the structure of
the human brain and how it's different
from non-human brains
so I got into the neurosciences to try
to find it in fact my PhD work was
tracing Connections in Monkey Brains to
try to find out what's fundamentally
different about human brains that makes
language possible
and this is where in interaction I
became interested in Noam Chomsky took
courses uh from him uh we never quite
agreed about this in part because of
course he's coming from it coming to
language from a formal point of view and
I was coming to language from a
biological point of view
where we came into conflict
um
was
was this an accident of evolution some
kind of magical thing that happened to
the brain a miracle that we don't
understand and it happened all at once
and language Pops in suddenly
um unfortunately doesn't explain very
much
um if you want to say well language is
you know there's some algorithm that
makes it possible and that's in the
brain
um as a biologist you want to explain
okay how is it organized you know what
parts of the brain are involved what
parts of the brain change between
chimpanzees and ourselves to make it not
only possible but easy I mean we acquire
language easily I mean even though you
know
multiple languages become more and more
difficult as we get older nevertheless
we're pretty good at it and and no other
species can even get close uh maybe not
even start although I think there's some
some evidence that they could start but
to get very far almost not at all so
there had to be something about the
brain and we knew that brains got bigger
uh that's one thing but bigger is a
pretty generic feature
um and I spent a lot of time studying
why human brains are in fact larger than
other primate brains for example and why
primate brains are on average larger for
their body size than any other mammals
and we've now shown that in fact the
size story is really a red herring in
lots of interesting ways and we can come
back to talk about that but but as a
result I became very much interested in
this and my PhD work basically showed
that there were no new parts the human
brain although bigger has more neurons
has no new kinds of structures in it
that do this it was a real Paradox so
that basically I was looking at the
connections between areas that we know
in the human brain
um are really involved critically in
this areas in the brain called brocos
area Inverness area and
I was looking at the connections between
them
um but doing so in Monkey Brains using
the techniques at the time that allowed
us to trace this out and what I found
was that everything in the monkey brain
predicted what we should expect in a
human brain uh it wasn't until uh a
couple of decades later with connective
connectivity being demonstrated in the
human brain using uh these various
connectome technologies that we've
developed um basically tractography it's
called these days in which we use fmri
like techniques to map out roughly what
the connections are in fact I could do
it microscopically of course in other
species we could look at actual synapses
and axons we're just sort of simulating
that even now but nevertheless what it
shows is that the connections that I was
able to demonstrate in monkey prints
between areas that had the same cellular
structure that we find in human brains
um they were all there but monkeys can't
do anything like what we can do and so
so it really sort of drove me in other
directions and it drove me to study
what's behind brain Evolution which is
brain development how it is that the
genes that determine what segments of
the nervous system partition into
different kinds of cells and how those
cells send out their output branches
their axons to connect to other cells in
the brain and so by studying this it
shifted my attention towards a technique
that would help me understand how that
might be in different species so all
through the 1990s I shifted my effort to
studying
um how this happens in development by
using fetal neurotransplantation
uh and what I was doing at this time was
was to take
um
immature fetal cells from one species
brain transplant them into a different
species brain and I had markers that I
could see the one kind of animal's cell
in another kind of brain so I could
actually look at how individual neurons
actually found their targets and what I
found is that in fact when we started
out by transplanting
um Pig cells Pig embryonic cells into
rat brains well we could actually see
the pig cell you know in this
environment of rat and see how the
connections were made it turns out that
the pig cells found appropriate Targets
in their app rate not only that if the
rat brain had been previously damaged so
it lost some function a transplanted Pig
cells could restore some of that
function we did this with kind of a
Parkinson's model all of this sort of
began to
to make the question even more difficult
in some respects
um but what I had found is that in the
enlargement of the brain
um it changes the relative way that
connections just get established and
think about in terms of our own voting
systems here
um we have what we call gerrymandering
going on in which you select a group
that are going to compete against
another group but you select it in such
a way so that one always wins over the
other well it turns out that quantity of
course matters
um in the development of of connections
within the brain
um there's a significant overt
production of axons and connections and
neurons in fact that then compete for
connecting to other neurons and that
competition is driven by a kind of a
heavy and like process as a process in
which
um the the the standards saying that we
use for students is that neurons that
fire together wire together that is what
happens is that there's
a competition in which synchrony is
actually an aid and that's because
there's actually a kind of it's almost
like a mini darwinian process uh where
you know Gerald Adelman decades ago
called this neural Darwinism uh but
basically that that that
they get fed
the receiving cell
um if it fires in synchrony with the
inputs it gives back a little bit of a
growth factor that keeps those axons
strong and those that are not in
synchrony just don't get it so it's
basically very much like natural
selection there's a kind of a food
competition going on here but in any
case uh what happens is as the brain
enlarges in some parts in large
differentially with respect to other
parts it biases that competition in
interesting ways and that bias
competition actually restructures the
connectivity not in an absolute sense
but in a relative sense some things are
more connected than others some things
are less connected than others and this
I think has explained
um how languages become possible I like
to describe it that the demands of
language the demands of symbolic
communication have actually
played a role in restructuring the brain
that is Generation upon generation
brains that did better at this
um uh were reproduced in those that did
worse at it we're not and that means
that the very fact of using
um initially very crude kind of symbolic
communication over the course of about
two million years has played a
significant role in restructuring the
human brain so that over time we've
become very good at it not because we
have some special language device or
some special algorithm that does it but
because we have
um hundreds of little tweaks
that in all different ways have made it
easy whether it's having to do with how
our hearing Works how our attention is
shifted uh all these various features
that are slight biases just make it
really easy for us to do this so the
actual the title of my mid-90s book uh
was a symbolic species referring to a
species that is adapted to the symbolic
world like you might say uh seals are
aquatic species we're symbolic species
um we've adapted to living in a world of
symbols and
um
I think of it sort of like a beaver in a
beaver dam uh beavers over the course of
millions of years have been damming up
rivers and streams to create an aquatic
environment beavers have become aquatic
mammals uh because of what they've done
to their environment we've become
symbolic mammals symbolic primates uh
because what we've done to our
environment we've adapted to that
environment by changing our bodies and
changing our behavioral capacities like
beavers have adapted to an aquatic
environment over the course of millions
of years flat Tails webbed feet uh the
capacity to hold their breath in
interesting ways you know and of course
to build dams
um all of this it falls into the
the term Niche construction that is
we've constructed a niche we do in every
generation we build this symbolic
cultural Niche that we have to adapt to
um and that something like that has been
going on uh at least according to the
work I've done I would guess that it's
been going on for at least two million
years slowly slowly modifying this
um
so this is the the Prelude to where I
want to go next because this is where
it's going to come back to your question
about you know what's fundamental to the
world
so one of the things that this said to
me is that somehow communicating
symbolically
requires a very different kind of
interpretive process than communicating
by likenesses icons or indices so when I
scream with pain that's an index it's
physically correlated physiologically
correlated with this state and that
means that you know every other human
being who has the same connection
actually immediately can interpret this
because they interpret it the same way
we laugh and we sub uh and because we
all do it the same way and it's
specifically connected with a particular
emotional state
um we understand it pretty well it's an
index like a fever is an index then it's
because of its physical correlation okay
um
on the other hand
um we also produce iconic communication
that is you know coloration I like to
think about um
mods that have eye spots on them
um a moth is sort of camouflaged sitting
on a tree until a bird flies by by and
maybe would eat it but if it disturbs it
the moth opens up its wings and then
sees eyes big eyes looking back at a
bird
um of course that's going to play a role
in affecting the birds communication the
bird's interpretation of what's going on
it might be dangerous maybe I shouldn't
eat this one
um so what's happened is of course it's
communicating iconically by likeness
um brains are really good at figuring
out what something is by virtue of what
it's like because they have lots of
other experiences
most of us share in the problem of being
so digitally active that we over consume
or over produce content which in turn
leads to an overwhelming amount of
monthly monetary subscription this
Channel's theme is exploration at least
one of the main themes and it's
difficult to paragonate when we're
handling the more routine and monotonous
items this is exactly why we're
partnering with today's sponsor rocket
money formerly known as true bill rocket
money automates the process of financial
saving and tackles the various
subscriptions that inevitably pile up
for all of us like Netflix phone bills
patreon subscriptions that aren't tow
Etc rocket money displays all of your
subscriptions tells you where you're
losing money and how to cancel them with
a single click of a button most of us
think that we spend approximately eighty
dollars a month on subscriptions but it
turns out that the average figure is in
excess of two hundred dollars get rid of
useless subscriptions with rocket money
now go to rocketmoney.com everything
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's rocketmoney.com everything
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now at rockmoney.com everything if
you want to avoid humdrum basic and
commonly monotonous gifts this year then
uncommon good is your secret weapon
Uncommon Goods is here to make your
holiday shopping stress free by scouring
the globe for the most remarkable and
unparalleled gifts for everyone whether
you're shopping for secret Santa or for
gifts for your entire family Uncommon
Goods knows precisely what they want
when you shop at Uncommon Goods you're
supporting artists and small independent
businesses These Fine products are often
made in small batches so it's best to
shop now before a certain item that you
like happens to sell out Uncommon Goods
looks for products that are high in
quality unique and often handmade or
made in the US they have some of the
most meaningful and out of the ordinary
gifts anywhere from art and jewelry to
Kitchen home and bar Uncommon Goods has
something for everyone so not the same
lackluster gifts that you can find just
anywhere additionally with every
purchase made and Uncommon Goods they
give back one dollar to a non-profit
partner of your choice so far they've
donated more than two and a half million
to get 50 15 off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.com everything that's
uncommongoods.com everything for 15 off
don't miss out on this limited time
offer on commongoods.com everything
about the moth example if it was the
eyes of the moth that it revealed so
somehow it had eyes on its wings would
that then be indexical because it would
be literal so it's it's in the sense now
it becomes both and this is what I'm
going to talk about in a few minutes and
that is there's a hierarchy here one
depends on the other in interesting ways
um if it wasn't the fact that birds
already had a way to interpret eyes
and recognizing that a particularly
large eyes looking straight ahead are
very likely to be a predator like an owl
or a cat of some kind
um it wouldn't have any effect at all
but now there's two things going on now
um
when the bird sees this
um it now triggers maybe some Behavior
be be wary of this
um that's an indexical relationship but
also when the moth opens its wings
suddenly
um it's also indexical because now the
bird knows that with this is not just
bark I've been looking at but there's
something else there
so if that's an index so there's both
indices and icons available here but
nervous systems since their beginning
and I would say life since its beginning
um has been about Discerning iconic and
indexical relationships so you know
think about uh a microorganism like E
coli you know it has to identify things
that are edible and non-edible
it iconically recognizes that that
sugar-like molecules and molecules that
are breakdown products of something
organic might in fact be a food source
they have a kind of a likeness to each
other their likeness is because these
are things by virtue of whatever traits
they carry whatever molecular features
they carry
um are interpreted by the receptor sites
on this microorganism as
a food food has a likeness there's a
certain trait that makes them alike but
now
it also if it's swimming around
um and it's moving around the gradient
of glucose might increase
um that becomes an index that there's a
diffusion away from some source so it's
a good idea to swim up that gradient of
higher higher concentration that becomes
an index so even as simple as a
bacterium has iconic and indexical means
this is a very this is the way
information is interpreted not just
carried but interpreted you have to have
a system that interprets it obviously if
sweet things are not what you're looking
for then you're not not going to have
that tendency
um
we have a lot of these of course we're
attracted to certain things and repelled
by certain things and they're icons and
indices of various kinds we can also
produce conventional icons in indices I
mean think about the stick figures on
restroom doors for example they're both
iconic in a crude sense
in part because of a convention that we
have I mean girls don't wear dresses
anymore skirts anymore and yet that's
typically the the figure in the west
that we still have on restroom doors
[Music]
um
it's there conventionally but also
because it's supposed to be iconic but
the fact that it's a fix to a particular
door is indexical it says that this
indicates that behind this door is
supposed to be males versus females
um so it play so icons and indices are
they're everywhere the question is how
do we develop a capacity to represent
something if the signed vehicle we're
using has no relationship to what it
represents that's the language problem
um and for years and this begins I I
would say hundreds of years back in time
um we've just sort of assumed that well
this is just a convention we just agree
that it does
um the problem is that conventions just
don't happen by accident
the problem is
um
yes a miracle could happen and give us
language
and allow us to have all the same ways
of doing it
um or
like any other convention any other
social habit it takes communication to
set it up
so think about any other thing that we
agree upon
to do a habit that we have socially to
establish that convention we have to
communicate about it
now that means you can't use a
convention to produce a convention
unless you already have a first
convention how do you get the first one
how do you get language when there's no
language when there's no other
conventional form of communication
and that is
just watch young children
they
recognize things that are like each
other
they communicate to others by sharing
objects of a certain kind they point or
reach that as pointing is an index
objects that you can play with or food
that's that's always food or drink
that's always drink there each instance
is Iconic of each other
so right away children are born like
other species with lots of iconic and
indexical capacity
and as the first year goes by and they
develop this unique way of indicating
that only we humans have which is
pointing with our fingers and hands
um and looking in particular directions
and watching somebody else's gaze these
are all indices
they're directly correlated with
something that's there so children build
up this conventionality
um slowly in the first year of Life they
have lots of information about
communication
um in order to build up a means of
communicating that lacks that in other
words to develop the conventionality
they also have to they have to use
iconic and indexical abilities
so one of the real challenges in
understanding the brain then is first of
all to understand that that whenever you
build up conventional communication I
like to call this displaced reference
it's because nothing about the signed
vehicle gives it away it's only the
sharing of of interpretive capacities it
gives it makes it work
um to share it of course we have to we
have to go through all of these
processes we're really good at it
um
my work has begun to pursue this even at
the molecular level we were just talking
about bacteria a minute ago but it turns
out that we see the same thing going on
even at the molecular level think about
the simple example of
how DNA produces proteins that have
interesting three-dimensional structures
DNA has a sequence of nucleotides every
three of them we call a codon it's
interesting we use the the metaphor of a
code here think about Morse code Morse
code is an arbitrary correlation between
dots and dashes and letters
um two conventions
and we've now linked them together with
a conventional Association because dots
and dashes aren't letters
um so we have exactly the kind of thing
that we're struggling with here a
conventional or symbolic form of
communication
um
codon
matches to an anticodon in a messenger
RNA molecule
so that in going from DNA to the
messenger RNA it's laid out in iconic
ways
that is the
messenger RNA now is a reflection of an
exact you know reverse isomorphism of
the DNA that took that information from
its nucleotide sequence corresponds
exactly to the one that's produced by
the DNA molecule
um then taken into a ribosome that
structure also made up of DNA I mean of
RNA and protein
um then takes in another kind of RNA
molecule Transfer RNA molecule which has
on one end of it
um three nucleotides which will match
again in anti what we call anticodon
fashion that is the reverse three that
now attaches it iconically to the
messenger RNA molecule
but on the other end of the transfer why
is it iconically attaches oh because
it's it's a mirror image
so it has all so we might say it
co-varies it's a covariance relationship
um and what we mean by if there's a
similarity in this case
um there's an inverse similarity so in
the DNA molecule the A's G C's and T's
um uh match up with
they're opposite so G and C you know
bind together a and t bind together uh
in the messenger RNA
um you replace one of them with another
one called uracil
um which is a slightly slightly related
uh nucleotide and then so now we've got
three things that bind together I'll say
only do it by by showing so you got RNA
molecule binding to the DNA molecule
it's now carries a mirror image in fact
it's up it's opposite side would be the
DNA molecule but now it then carries
over and binds to here I've got my RNA
molecule coming across here and it binds
to
um another RNA molecule the transfer RNA
molecule
um so the the three bases in the DNA
molecule mapped to three bases in the
RNA model in messenger RNA molecule
which may up to three bases in the
transfer RNA molecule which is now since
this is the the reverse the mirror image
now it binds again and you've got the
original image back
so what you have is you've maintained
the form
the form or what I would call the
constraint the sequence constraint has
been maintained so we would say that by
covariance relationship information has
been transferred okay okay so constraint
is the same as information in this case
or no so all I'm going to show you is is
how they're this the same but it turns
out there's a hierarchic relationship
that we have to keep in in mind in order
to show this this was lost in
information Theory originally in the
1940s and 50s and it needs to be brought
back and I'll explain why in a minute
but the idea is that so now there's a
covariance relationship we've passed
this covariance from one molecule to
another molecule to a third molecule
that transfer RNA molecule has also got
at the other end of it an amino acid and
each three
codons on one end is matched to a
specific amino acid on the other end
that amino acid is now brought together
these three attach to the next three to
the next three different amino acids
correspond to the different codon
and now by bringing together
um different Transfer RNA molecules
you're also bringing together
different
amino acids
so that now what's happening there's a
continuity relationship or a correlation
relationship
that correlation relationship is now
also correlating amino acids which tend
to get stuck together and they produce a
long string of amino acids that is coded
for in the sequence in the DNA molecule
so now we have gone from a DNA molecule
by a covariance relationship and to the
RNA molecule which has a correlational
relationship and neighboring Transfer
RNA molecules now provide amino acids
with a correlational relationship so by
virtue of taking
um similarity relationship covariance
relationship and then a correlation
relationship we've now allowed DNA
molecule which has no relationship to
proteins as as molecules proteins are
made up of totally different molecules
in a string that tend to fold up because
of their electrical and hydrophobic and
hydrophilic potentials into
three-dimensional structures
that linear structure has passed its
information on through these multiple
steps to a totally different kind of
molecule
which can now interact with other
proteins and other kinds of molecules to
produce most of the work of the cell
what happened is the reason we call this
a codon relationship is there's a
code-like relationship between them that
is what we've done is we figured out in
biology now Evolution has figured this
out so to speak
um how to take a linear relationship in
one kind of molecule and create a
particular kind of three-dimensional
molecule made up of totally different
kinds of atoms that is made up of amino
acids as opposed to nuclei nucleotides
and
its function is determined by its
three-dimensional structure by how it's
folded
so in effect there's almost no
relationship between them you would this
is why thinking of it as a code it's not
crazy it's it's arbitrary and yet the
arbitrarity has been produced by this
multi-step process that links covariance
with correlation
in a way that allows this to happen that
I like to call covariance relationships
and correlation relationships grounded
they're grounded because the vehicle
that carries it is carrying some feature
in common with what it represents with
the information that it's carrying so if
it's a likeness relation if it's a
covariant covariance relationship it's
carrying some kind of formal feature
forward into another kind of molecule
whereas if it's just physically
correlated struck together
not by virtue of likeness but by simply
by virtue of being next to each other
being correlated being attached
um that also is grounded physically
grounded one is formally grounded and
one is physically grounded okay but by
stacking one on top of the other it now
produces the kind of distance between
where you started and where you end so
that now there's a what I call displaced
reference the information in the DNA
molecule is there in the protein but in
a totally different form there's been a
continuity of information transfer
um but a complete loss of groundedness
at the physical level and yet there's an
informational ground in this because
you've transferred
the same correlations
as a result there could be selection
that affects proteins and how they
interact and that'll select for
particular sequences of genes that
produce those useful proteins even
though they're totally separate kinds of
molecules
it adds one further feature that I think
is also important to think about it in
terms of the mathematics of all of this
that is the protein now has a
three-dimensional structure but DNA also
has a three-dimensional structure it's
twist and its twist is slightly
different depending on which
nucleotides are in that sequence
now my watch is talking to me just a
minute let me set it down it's all right
we'll repeat that last part the DNA so
the DNA sequence is of nucleotides but
it turns out that we we think about the
DNA molecule as as a Twist as a helix it
turns out that the Helix is slightly
differently Twisted depending on the
sequence
so it's not a uniform twist all the way
up so depending on the actual rung in
the ladder or depending on a sequence of
rungs no depending on the sequence of
Rooks the sequence of rungs make it
tight more tightly twisted or more
Loosely twisted depending on what the
sequence is and that means that there's
a three-dimensional structure to the DNA
molecule so it turns out that there are
some proteins that are produced produced
by virtue of being you know the
information taken off the DNA molecule
that are structured in such a way that
they can bind into the twist so there's
information that's passed from the DNA
to the protein and then there's also
structural information in terms of the
zeros and ones that we ordinarily think
of so those are the rungs and then
there's also structural information in
the sense that certain sequences of
those zeros and ones physically produce
a different structure in the DNA and
right it's not to say necessarily that
the protein then copies that but it
somehow relates no no the proteins don't
copy I want to be clear what this says
is that because
the protein molecule is a totally
different kind of molecule but it has
three-dimensional shape
what that means is that some proteins we
call them transcription factors
actually bind to DNA by fitting with a
Twist
and since that twist is determined by
the sequence
then what's happened is that the
proteins identify a region of the DNA
molecule
and as a result those proteins can play
a role in up regulating or down
regulating the expression
of genes
so now you have recursion possible
so what's happened by virtue of this
displacement from one kind of
information
that is sequence information zero and
one information you might think about it
um two three-dimensional physical
information
because they are both embodied
physically
they're capable of interacting but now
on a totally different basis
now the protein can regulate the DNA
that produces proteins
by virtue of this displacement of
reference
it's possible to now have that displaced
molecule regulate the kind of molecule
that produced it
this is recursion but notice that this
is a kind of interesting recursion it's
very similar to the gridelian recursion
what you need to have even a simple
Paradox like a liar's Paradox is that
you can't stop interpreting because it
refers to itself the Liars Paradox the
simplest one is of course this statement
is a lie or this statement is false
um once you interpret it you have to
reapply it back to the statement
originally you can't stop interpreting
because if it's a lie then it must it
must not be true but if it must not be
true then it's a lie then it's a lie so
it must be true the classic the classic
circularity here this is the basis in a
much more complicated version of
girdle's incompleteness proof for
mathematics
um that is basically you have to have
some way that something can refer to
itself it has to have this kind of
recursion the point here is that that
recursion is possible with DNA and
proteins because of this displacement
DNA and RNA have to be linked to each
other by likeness relationships
um but DNA and proteins have totally
different reasons for having the
physical structures they they have but
as a result now you can have DNA
modified DNA indirectly through proteins
this hierarchy of communication in very
simple genetics is what makes possible
the complexity of bodies and cells
you've got to have this kind of
recursion because now the DNA can play a
role through Communications through
other interactions with the cell because
the proteins are now carrying
information also about their interaction
with other proteins maybe even with the
world that information can now modify
how genes produce and expressed
um so the complexity becomes possible
people in semiotics have talked about
this as scaffolding that is you're
building up new levels of information
that can now be a basis for building up
yet higher order information
so in fact this relationship I've just
talked about is what makes it possible
to have
um
complicated multi-celled bodies that
have repeated Parts think about the
multiple legs on insects or the multiple
ribs or the multiple vertebrae in our
bodies this is the result of exactly
this kind of transcription Factor effect
that is proteins that produce genes that
modify other genes well it turns out
that that with by a series of other
features
um genes have duplicated and varied and
you're producing this in a sort of theme
and variation fashion once you have
recursion you can do sort of theme
variation effects
um higher order effects and this is what
produces the sort of the what you might
call the theme and variation repeated
bodily parts that makes plants and
animals possible
so in effect what I became very
interested in and this is really uh by
the end of the 1990s
was not only that I'm finding that
there's a lot of
um
indirect causality that makes this
possible in the brain and how it must
have been possible neurologically but it
now tells me that there's a way that
this is relevant to biology and maybe
something as universal as mathematics
itself that this same hierarchical
relationship how you get recursion how
you make recursion possible
um has to do with this what I call I
describe this sort of characteristically
as one two three repeat
one
the iconicity that is the co-variation
okay two
correlation physical correlation in some
respects and three displacement
once you've displaced you can now go
back and have that displaced reference
modify one
two three repeat
um is giving you this this capacity for
recursion
now one of the things that I realized at
this point is that it also helped me
understand why Noam Chomsky and I were
having so much trouble agreeing about
what he called Universal grammar
when I wrote in the mid-1990s about the
evolution of language mostly from the
point of view of what's changed in the
brain
um I was saying that look
um Universal grammar has a genetically
predisposed feature is
evolutionarily essentially impossible
it's impossible for the same reason that
we don't have innate words
for something to be selected in the
course of evolution it has to first of
all be consistently repeated again and
again and again in the world
its relationship to something that's
relevant to life has to also be a strong
correlation
it's got to have these same features
repeat it again and again and again
that's iconic
um having a correlation is something
relevant like survival value food
Predator defense whatever
um that's a physical correlation that
has to be there true
but then to develop the evolution of
this this selection has to be repeated
again and again and the substrate in the
body
that's now going to put those together
to hold them together that is the
adaptation has to be produced by this
recursive process happening again and
again in the course of evolution
words for example the reason we don't
have innate words
is simple
and that is words change their meaning
pretty rapidly
um they don't persist generation upon
generation for thousands of years in
just a thousand of years Thousand Years
a language that has split can become
totally non-intertranslatable
and we've seen that of course in the
history of Europe for the most part
um but the same thing is true in
evolution but much much larger there's
the constancy must go on for hundreds of
generations to really make a dent in the
biology of the organism
so words of course don't have this
feature they change too fast their
association with things in the world is
too fleeting and flexible and finally
they don't have much of a reproductive
consequence
in order for mutations to have any kind
of effect at all they have to be the
same over and over and over again and
they have to have a reproductive
consequence words don't have this and so
we have to learn words socially we have
to trans transmit them from person to
person from so from in social groups
um in fact you have to have a larger
social group to remember all that
information to hold it collectively
um now think about grammar
grammar is even more abstract than words
grammar has fewer constraints in part
because it's not directly correlated
with things in the world at least my
word dog and my word drink I have
something physically correlated in the
world it's just not very stable and
regular
over the course of evolutionary time so
it can't evolve biologically as the tow
project grows we get plenty of sponsors
coming and I thought you know this one
is a fascinating company our new sponsor
is Masterworks Masterworks is the only
platform that allows you to invest in
multi-million dollar works of art by
Picasso Banksy and more Masterworks is
giving you access to invest in Fine Art
which is usually only accessible to
multi-millionaires or billionaires the
art that you see hanging in museums can
now be partially owned by you the
inventive part is that you don't need to
know the details of art or investing
Masterworks makes the whole process
straightforward with a clean interface
and exceptional customer service they
are innovating as more traditional
Investments suffer last month we
verified a cell which had a 21.5 return
so for instance if you were to put ten
thousand dollars in you would now have
twelve thousand Welcome to our new
sponsor Masterworks and the link to them
is in the description just so you know
there's in fact a wait list to join
their platform right now however total
listeners can skip the wait list and get
Priority Access to their new offerings
by clicking the link in this description
or going to masterworks.com and using
the promo code toe that is toe that's
masterworks.com promo code toe or click
the link in the description just to make
this distinction between indexical
symbolic and iconic more clear for
people when you said the word dog that's
symbolic and when you went like this
drink that's symbolic but also indexical
because you showed something
exactly and I'm gonna this is what's
gonna get us back to finally back to
syntax
um why I think
um
After Reading Writing the theme box I
just want to make it clear syntax is a
synonym for grammar in this case
grammar and syntax just refers mostly to
relative positions of things uh in a
sequence so we can talk about the syntax
of uh of symbols in a mathematical
equation
and how you have to the syntax is how
you have to move them around who can be
next to who who can't be next to who who
can modify who and so on what
constitutes a well-formed sentence yeah
exactly okay so grammar is the specific
kind of constraints on that
that language has
so grammar can tell you there's certain
kinds of words that are content words
certain kinds of words that play the
role of a of a verb or a noun or a
pronoun uh because of their kind they
have to be connected with other words in
a particular way
you can't just randomly throw words
together and have them work
they have to have both a sequence that's
maybe characteristically different in
different languages
but most languages have words that play
the role of a verb or a noun for example
those are chomsky's universes
and there are many of them Chomsky talks
about lots of syntactical operations
that are that he says are going to be
Universal around the world he he
developed this interestingly enough in
the 19 early late 1950s early 1960s
um
by virtue of his knowledge
um of something else that I thought was
just just brilliant about his his
realization back then which was
um comparing how you analyze grammar and
syntax to a turing machine
not to a turing machine as a machine but
the abstract nature of a touring machine
that is an algorithm a specifically
described sequence of operations a
touring machine logic
can be laid out as a replacement logic
string a can be replaced by string B
um that is a rewrite rule
that's what the turing machine is about
it's about having specific rewrite rules
so you read a particular
symbol and you rewrite another symbol
somewhere else and you have a rule for
that Chomsky realized in his book
syntactic structures written in the
early 60s that you could describe syntax
and grammar like a turing machine with a
series of rewrite rules
that was a brilliant recognition now
what's happening at this point in time
in history of course is Computing is
finally being figured out we're working
out the abstract nature of computing
uh Chomsky is struggling with the
abstract nature of language
and he says wow this is interesting
here's here's both the value and the
problem
the value is that a touring machine
can describe any
completely describable operation so so
so so let me get the power of a turing
machine is it's Universal
we talk about this as a universal turing
machine interesting okay now you're
beginning to see the connection here now
if we think of grammar and syntax as
being
producible by a turing machine
by a universal machine
then that suggests that grammar and
syntax itself might be Universal and
that there's a a particular turing
machine in the brain of every human
being
that produces its grammar and syntax
and that once we figure out what words
mean what they refer to in the world we
can now just turn on our Universal
turing machine it's not Universal
anymore it's a specific Tory machine
that has specific rules for rewrite and
you can produce grammar and syntax that
becomes the original and I think
brilliant discovery that Noam Chomsky
makes in the early 1960s but of course
it now that it begs another question
where does it come from
where does this touring machine come
from
well
maybe it's in the brain and of course we
begin thinking about brains as computers
about this time we begin to use this
sort of computational metaphor to talk
about thought a very powerful tool for
cognitive science for studying brains in
a much more systematic way and our
behaviors and our cognition and so on
um but now if you think about brains as
a a machine
as a Computing machine
then it suggests that well maybe an
algorithm evolved
so people began thinking
um really it took about 10 15 20 years
for people beginning to move in a
direction the Chomsky had already begun
to assess which is that if we think
about cognition as computation
um then we can think about language as
run by a turing machine
um in the brain an algorithm and that
that algorithm could have evolved
so that it's a very straightforward good
argument logical argument about this the
only problem is
um the one I just mentioned before this
and that is what makes something
evolvable
grammar and syntax and even words are
not evolvable biologically
they have to be evolvable socially
but that's a problem and it's a problem
because if it's just evolvable socially
you might think well there should be all
kinds of different grammars all kinds of
languages that are totally unlike each
other
Chomsky was clearly right that languages
have a lot of things in common
they have a lot of syntactical
constraints that you can't do certain
things and you have to do certain other
things everything like a sentence for
example has to have at least two parts
um and this in fact became an Insight
that that helped me think this through
um why do sentences have to have more
than one word
we do have a few things that communicate
um what we call holophrastic that means
a single word a single announcement is
to communicate something the classic
example is sitting in a in a crowded
theater and yelling fire
um suddenly everybody knows that this is
it indicates that someone thinks
that there's fire here immediately
present
it's it's an index in the sense that
it's says that physically it's
correlated with my producing this sound
um but this
is interesting think about the word
um
loud
okay
um loud brings to mind by association
soft sweet
um garish you know a whole bunch of
associations can come up with it
um but loud doesn't refer to anything
particular by itself
Noam Chomsky of course has struggled
with this as linguists have for for
Generations words don't exactly refer to
specific things with the exception of
proper nouns the name Chicago refers to
a specific city
um but city does not
um
now let's go back to the word loud
um loud doesn't refer to anything
particular
but how about this
loud
now it does right
it was correlated
with a loud sound
now that correlation says that Lao
doesn't just refer to some abstract
relationship it actually refers to
something physical in the world
I couldn't said clapping my hands is
loud
the phrase clapping my hands does the
same thing as this
because it's correlated in the sentence
with the word loud
clapping my hands is an index
but the correlation of the word
spoken in quick succession with the
sound of clapping my hands also is
indexical it's a correlation
so what's happened is that in order for
words
to refer specifically to things
they need to be coupled with an index
and that's of course what pointing does
for acquiring language in the first
place it's an index that allows children
to correlate a sound with something in
the world
now how would a blind person yeah well
so a blind person you can't Point uh now
you have to touch
but touching is of course a version of
pointing pointing is a physical
correlation just with some distance
physical correlation without distance
sure
um to really communicate you have to do
it that way
but what it basically says is that the
reason that all languages have something
like a sentence where there's multiple
kinds of words that have different
functions is that you've got to have
these two semiotic functions together
otherwise symbols abstract things can't
refer
so this again
replays this relationship in a bunch of
different ways I've now described it in
terms of sentences but described it in
terms of DNA and proteins and described
it in terms of mathematics and it is
referring to meaning or reference or
what you know this relationship is one
two three repeat relationship how you
get displaced reference how you can get
something that refers to something that
it's not even though it has nothing
physically in common with it nothing
formally in common with it
so words have this referential
capability but this is of course also
the DNA story DNA doesn't have anything
in common
um with the weather
with the kind of food you have to eat
radically displaced away from it
and yet the information can be shared
between bodies and behaviors and DNA
molecules
this incredible difference
by virtue of this continuity that's
established
this is what I say is a little bit like
mathematics
here's how I want to characterize
mathematics versus language
mathematics
you're required not to have
confusion
you've got to keep things separate
distinct
distinction is the absolute most
important thing you can't run any on
when a mathematical operation where one
becomes five
or some value that you've fixed
is unfixed
um okay so precision
precision and precise it has to be
absolutely precise you have no
freedom to vary that's a constraint that
says all of my referential operations
are constrained to maintain this one
thing in common
um in language
um the constraints have to be weaker
they have to be weaker for a number of
reasons
what we want is of course not to have
confusion
not to confound things not to have
ambiguity but we can survive with some
degree of ambiguity we can't do that in
mathematics we have to get rid of that
ambiguity this is why girdle's
incompleteness proof was so problematic
so Troublesome for people because it
said that you can't have a system that
completely gets rid of
ambiguity
and have it closed and complete it has
to be either if it's capable of getting
rid of ambiguity it has to be open
if it gets rid of ambiguity
um it's simple
so so girdle basically shows that you
can't get rid of it completely and I
think semiotics basically tells us this
you can't get rid of it completely
but you can build on it
and you can make it more and more
um complex so
to get us back to the mathematical
comparison to language language has to
also minimize ambiguity
but of course ambiguities only so
Troublesome as the problem you're having
to face
the particular pragmatic details in fact
here I am trying to communicate this to
you to you and to an audience
um you maybe don't have to get all the
details
you may be able to build up the details
as we talk more and more and more
understand what the what the words refer
to how it works in a sense
um
in this process
even two sentences later you've
forgotten the sentence that came before
that you've translated it into something
totally different than words
into maybe images to maybe sort of
feelings in your body right whatever you
know we've extracted
yeah
in mathematics that means we can make it
as
hard to penetrate as as we need so long
as our manipulations the operations we
use
verify discreetness don't allow you know
a to equal B if a and b are not the same
um that means that mathematics is
symbolic communication
that is highly constrained
but we don't have to interpret it right
away it may take years or never to
understand a particular equation a
particular level of mathematical
complexity
um because we can look at it reflect on
it look at it reflect on it
try things out maybe transfer the
equations into some physical like
relationship analogy like a graph for
example to try to understand what it
means and how it works
um
in language of course we have to do it
in real time
we don't have the luxury
so that the linguistic capacity
um also has a constraint but the
constraints are much weaker much looser
and they're just simply limited to what
I want to accomplish now what needs to
be transmitted at this moment oftentimes
the details don't are not going to
matter
so this is a case of language in in the
case of
um genetics
it's somewhere in between it's not as
precise as mathematics there's lots of
folding abnormalities that can happen in
fact one thing that happens with
translating from DNA to messenger RNA
um in cells like yours and mine uh
eukaryotic cells
um the RNA molecules are carrying a lot
of
non-protein information what we call
introns strings within the DNA molecule
that are just simply not carrying
information that will play any role in
the eventual protein and so in
eukaryotic cells we have a structure
called a spliceosome a complicated
structure made up of five RNA molecules
that themselves have three-dimensional
structure because of the way they stick
together in fold and literally dozens of
different protein molecules that can
bind and disconnect and rebind
the spliceosome splices out the introns
the RNA molecule is full of noise
segments that aren't not going to be
useful
the spliceosome figures out which ones
are not going to be useful Cuts them out
and re-splices the RNA molecule back
together
so that the eventual RNA molecule that
gets sent to the ribosome to turn into a
protein to generate a protein
it's now been cleaned up spliced out all
the useless stuff
to have a system that has this kind of
noise in it means that that in fact
there's a little bit of
flux in the system things aren't exact
per exactly perfect and so in that
respect you know it's a little bit
between mathematics and language in that
respect but the same constraints
are necessary you need the same three
ways of representing things one two and
three
um those are universals and that means
that it's going to be also true for
language and for mathematics mathematics
is going to have to respect those
features as well the equal sign in in an
equation
is about covariance about iconicity this
equation is the same as this equation so
long as you do the right operations
that's what the equal sign is saying
having
operations next to the variables so how
is this all related to meaning and even
sentience
right so it absolutely is
um
maybe we'll go to sentience first
because that might help a little bit
um that is you might call it the hard
problem I I don't think it's a hard
problem I think it's a counter-intuitive
problem
um and and I think that's that's the
challenge in the same way that what I
just described is probably
counter-intuitive because we think about
codes so naturally
like codes do it all the problem is the
code already assumes representation
a code doesn't give you representation
you know the dots and dashes and the
letters already represent something
the dots and dashes represent letters
the letters represent parts of a
sentence parts of a word
um we've already assumed that we know
the meaning for that so that the morse
code carries the meaning because the
meaning was established outside of the
code relationship
um
when you think about and this is I think
the problem that I find with Linguistics
in general
because Linguistics has accepted the
code relationship between words and
meanings
um it has a number of problems one of
the problems is that in a code there's a
one-to-one matching between something
and something else that is you know
three dots mean something
okay it's the s
um it matches specifically one to one
but in a word of course we know that
words don't match one to one except for
um proper nouns proper names
um words map and not to a thing but
oftentimes to something we often call a
meaning or a sense of something
and that's not like a code and so one of
the first problems is we're beginning to
we treat language as though it's a code
although it's not a code
so a code is devoid of meaning
so the code relationship the stand-in
relationship or something can stand in
for something else
um is itself not about meaning something
it's just about standing in for
something else
um the question is how does it stand in
for something else it stands in for
something else for somebody that
interprets it
So that obviously Morse Code by itself
if not interpreted it's just sounds or
dots or blips uh you know coming across
some some line
um the same thing is with words of
course if I don't understand the
language it's just sound
um it doesn't have any reference the
question is how does that reference get
established how does the meaning get
established going back to the beginning
of 20th century into the 19th century
the philosopher got loved frege
distinguished two aspects of reference
he talked about it as sense and
reference or in German
since is the sense of the meaning of
something
um and it's also been called the
intention of something
um
and the reference is something in the
world that refers to he called that the
uh bidoitum or the reference
um sometimes called the extension of
something can you give an example so
yeah I'll give an example so and this
comes directly from a brilliant idea he
said that look we have the names uh
Hesperus and phosphorus
for the morning star and the evening
star
but in fact they have two different
meanings Morning Star and evening star
and the names
talk about something they actually
describe something
although phosphorus and Hesperus um are
just names for what they described their
names for something in particular but it
turns out their names for the planet
Venus the actual extension the physical
extension is the same thing
even though the words are different and
they and they refer to different senses
the sense of Morningstar and the sense
of evening star have a different sense
but what they refer to in the world is a
thing a particular thing one
um so what he says is that sense and
reference are different
and then we talk about meaning we
oftentimes confuse these
and we confuse it with something even
more complicated
usefulness or significance or value
what's the meaning of what I've been
saying
it's not just the words it's not just
the reference it's not just that
something in the world it's actually is
it useful is it helpful is it valuable
the meaning of something so the word
meaning is really ambiguous because it
it brings all these things together so I
I actually don't like to use the word
um I don't like to use the word because
what's the meaning of the white line
down the middle of the road
well it doesn't have a meaning like a
word it doesn't have a definition
um and it doesn't refer to anything
particular it actually indicates
where you should drive it's an index
um it's a conventionalized index
now you have to know what it what that
index is what you have to know what the
convention was
um uh and for the most part it takes
language to figure that out
but
in many respects in many respects it's
not
that meaning is telling you something
it's that we want to distinguish those
things that we think have to do with
meaning and this is where this iconic
indexical and symbolic feature help out
because symbols can have all of those
features
so a word can have
value
usefulness a particular neologism in
science that can be very useful because
it picks out something that wasn't
picked out before that we need to
understand and distinguish
um
the
word itself can refer to some general
type of things a description of things
um so the word symbol
unfortunately is used both to refer to
tokens like the letters that show up on
the screen
um and
um a religious artifact
the word symbol is itself very sort of
multi-facet and and ambiguous but in
context of course we
specify what it means but in fact using
the word symbol to talk about an
alphanumeric character is actually
sneaking something in
and let me give a sense of this
um
an alphanumeric character is something
we've agreed on
to be an arbitrary
sign
to code for a particular sound in a
phonetic language
therefore it's it's playing a code like
or symbolic-like role it's displaced
from what it refers to
this has no com no characteristics in
common
um on the other hand
um
if my computer screen starts to spew at
random all kinds of alphanumeric
characters
they're not symbols they don't refer to
anything symbolically they're actually
indices they indicate that there's
something going wrong in my computer
so they're which is interesting because
in that case the noise is a form of a
signal
that's exactly right and that and what
this tells us in information theory is
that the distinction between noise and
signal
is not intrinsic
it's something that has to do with
interpretation okay is that always the
case now is there a non-trivial example
so for instance if a computer is not
working then we would see the fact that
it's not working as a form of noise so
you mentioned just some pixels on the
screen and then we say that noise is Sim
noise is symbolic or is referential to
the repairman
right case right particular kind of
noise now can carry
information but the same thing is true
think about you know in simple shannoni
and information Theory
um you have you have a signal that's got
a certain level of noise what he argued
is that
adding redundancy to some level can help
us discern what signal what's noise
because the signal will be redundantly
repeated in each repetition whereas the
noise produced by an independent Source
will not be repeated and so we can
basically figure out where it comes from
but if the noise itself has structure
then that can carry information about
the source of that noise
if the noise is not purely random
it can be confused with a signal
but in fact that non-randomeness is
telling some telling us something about
where it comes from and one of things I
like to say about information Theory
um and this is just brought back to us
with the people like landauer and others
who developed computational theories and
quantum theories of information is that
anything that carries information is a
physical thing
that is it's either some energetic or
some material object or maybe some
process
um but that means that it has a certain
degree of entropy
as a certain redundancy in turn and a
certain lack of redundancy to its
structure
um and it's particularly the constraint
that is the redundancy that usually
carries the information
that's because and that can be picked
out that's what Shannon has told us when
he says that by increasing the
redundancy of a noisy signal
um we can discern what's signal and
what's noise
um now what we're doing is we're saying
I know it's signal I don't know what
it's signal about
but
um it's redundant so it's it's carrying
more information because there's
redundancy it's actually eliminating
some uncertainty uh which is Shannon's
ultimate measure but notice that that
the Shannon theory of information is
just about the medium itself
when we say that um
alphanumeric characters spewed on my
screen at random
um I call them symbols showing up on my
screen I'm using symbol in the
shannonian sense talking about the
medium itself
but here's the interesting thing the
medium itself
has iconic and indexical relationships
to the world that it's referring to
so one of the stories about where do we
get information why does redundancy of a
signal provide us information about
something because the redundancy the
constraint on that signal
um is there because not all degrees of
freedom not fully Randomness Randomness
was in that signal
physical system that is not at its
lowest energy state that is at highest
entropy state
is there because it was pushed away from
its highest entropy State work had to be
done something has prevented it from
going to its lowest energy highest
entropy state
but what that tells you is that if the
entropy of the signal
both the Shannon entropy and the
physical entropy
are reduced it's because it's in
relation to something else that is
producing that constraint work has been
done
to either prevent it
from His Highest entropy or push it away
from Full entropy so there's some
redundancy in it
every scientific tool uses this trick
in other words this is how we get
indexical information about the world
how an experiment which manipulates the
world produces certain regularities or
irregularities and it's those that are
carrying the information they do so
um because communication is physical
because it's physical all of this
abstract stuff we've been talking about
has another piece to it that is it's
always grounded in the world
and to unground it to use a kind of
communication that's code-like we need
to go through these steps to D to
unground it language is ungrounded in
this sense right okay so this is what's
known as the symbolic grounding problem
correct
the simple grounding problem right you
please like reiterate what is the symbol
grounding problem and also the
definition of grounding simple grounding
problem also sometimes called The Empty
symbol problem
is that um
how is it
that a word or a particular machine
state in your your artificial
intelligence machine
um is somehow linked to the world is
grounded to the world that its reference
has been fixed or established
so there's now an informational link so
that we know what this feature is the
symbol this arbitrary sound or squiggle
how it's linked to Something in the
world we know how we do it we say Okay
Morse code I'm going to call three dots
s
I'm going to say that
but of course I can't if I want to
explain how it starts
how do I get reference in the first
place how do I get symbolic reference
how do I get
two things that are unrelated to now
become fixed in their relationship so
whenever you see one you think the other
one
can you give another example
well so my cat
go ahead do you suggest something and
we'll talk talk it through how is the
word cat a problem like we say cat we
mean cat right so the word cat for most
people in the world has nothing to do
with this this mammal this small furry
mammal right it's called a little
carnivore that's about quietly judges
you
right right so the
how do you acquire it
um if you're a child
that don't doesn't have language yet how
do you acquire that word
well you have to first of all you have
to have some familiarity with cats or
maybe just familiarity with four-legged
animals
um and somebody shows you a cat
points to it cat
and kids
also have another bias that helps them
with language we tend to copy each
other's sounds
so they say cat they point now a dog
walks by
a day later and they point and they say
cat
now the question is what do they see
they've referred to something they've
made an iconic guess the sound is the
same cat sounds the same and there's
some similarity between this first
object and the second object
somebody says no that's a dog okay now
now the infant has a problem what's the
difference between cats and dogs
you've got dog whatever the word dog
comes up I see a four-legged creature
whenever the word cat comes up I see a
four-legged creature now I have to say
Okay what distinguishes them what's
non-iconic between them and
the
the words because they're iconically
used cat cat cat cat every time it's
repeated it suggests that I need to look
for a correlated object that has also
got similar features
dog dog dog dog
it's iconic itself the sounds are iconic
each time it's produced and it's this
you've got to figure out what's in
common each time and what's different in
each time what's in common is of course
iconic what's different is indexical but
what things stand out that indicates
that this is not that
what are the different features so what
we're doing in the process of acquiring
word meanings is using this indexical
iconic Bridge
to eventually say that now I can develop
this habit of thinking that only these
objects these four-legged small purring
objects are related to the word cat
um so what's happened is that you're
building up this interpretive habit
and the interpretive habit is built up
by the scaffolding of likeness and
correlation so where's the problem
where's the problem in the symbol
grounding problem sounds like this is
working fine children of course this is
working fine for kids right this is
actually the how you ground symbols
um the question is
um if you start from given symbols and
given things in the world how do they
get grounded if you ignore these
features there is no way that they can
be grounded
so in terms of now let's let's think
about computing
how is it that you ground
um think about even more sophisticated
Computing like machine learning in which
we'll use neural nets for example to
identify cats on on the internet
um how do they do it well what we do is
of course we show them thousands and
thousands of images of cats
um and we strengthen and and
weaken certain links in this system so
that eventually it converges
so that
what's happened is that each cat has
some things in common
each image has some things in common
each image has some things that are
different from other kinds of images
and what's happening is that each of
those in common we strengthen
certain synapses connections
correlations and we weaken others
so again even there we're using this
iconic and indexical logic to zero in to
produce so that the final state of the
machine it it pumps out the word cat
when we show it a cat picture okay now
does it understand that's what the cap
means
that's what the word means
this is
the problem of sentience of course is
the is the machine sentient
of the relationship between this
typographical sequence and these
pictures
um we're beginning to discover now that
in fact they do it very different than
we do it first of all
um which is one of the reasons why we
need thousands and thousands of examples
to make it work
um
but the other thing we're realizing is
that in effect this is just an arbitrary
correlation
the correlation is with us we've decided
we've done the job of
pruning the network
um we already know the interpretation
the interpretation there was there ahead
of time we just wanted to build it up
we have to build it up in the same way
but the interpretation is outside of
this process the machine doesn't know
that these three letters have to do with
an animal out there because as soon as
we show it animals unless it sees the
animal
um and sees it in a perspective that's
sort of like what the machine sees it's
going to get it wrong and there's all
kinds of ways of course we figured out
how to strengthen this using moving
objects moving objects in front of
backgrounds that kind of thing you know
changing the foreground background a lot
you know all these ways that we
strengthen that process but again the
machine is just got the physical
correlation
nothing else
the question is what is that something
else and that's of course we're after we
talk about minds and brains the key to
this story that I've led up to that
really followed all my work when the
nervous system and language
um
when I began to see that it had some
relevance to molecular biology
and therefore evolution
I realized that it also probably had a
relationship to
how the physical world has produced this
stuff
the one two three repeat story turns out
to be much more General than I ever
thought and so by the middle of the
2000s by 2010 and 2011 and 2012 when I
produced this book in complete nature
um I had begun to think that this was a
real problem that was much more General
relevant
to physics chemistry biology as well as
brains and evolution
and
the press the question was
how is it that creatures like us
that have ends in mind they're
teleological they have purposes
that can have meanings
if you think about meanings there can be
good meanings and bad meanings right
meanings and wrong meanings
incorrect Solutions and correct
Solutions
there's no correct chemistry and
incorrect chemistry
there's no correctness or incorrectness
or good or bad physics
as good or bad representations of
physics or good good and bad predictions
about chemistry but actual chemistry and
actual physics there's no normative
feature there's no no right wrong good
bad
but that's something that every organism
has there's good things or bad things
even for viruses
but but not for water
so one of the questions in it's a deep
philosophical question to some extent
but how is it that the material world
the physical world has produced
creatures
like us like bacteria that are normative
that actually divide the world into good
or bad useful or unuseful
notice that that's the other aspect of
meaning meaning is about value
and one of the deepest problems in
philosophy is where does value come from
what I was realizing is that this
there's an analogous problem here
an analogous problem that's not
semiotic in all the ways I talked about
but the constraints that produce
semiotics
has something to do with this problem as
well
with the problem of how a totally new
kind of property or relationship
being about something
can come into the world
although we can talk about
distributions in the physical world in
terms of information
how much information is contained on
your hard disk how much information is
expressed on a piece of paper or how
much information
is destroyed as a black hole sucks in
material from the outside world that's
just a measure of differences it's not
information that's about anything
we make it about things
it has to be interpreted to be about
something oh
we're gonna have to wait because my
dog's gonna bark for a few minutes here
can you can hear the dog in the
background yeah but but it's fine it's
minute continue yeah because Zoom has
denoising
good that's wonderful I love it so
um
the situation here is aboutness this is
a phrase that's sort of banded around by
physicists um excuse me by by
philosophers to talk about something
that's different than what the
physicists want to talk about
information information can be about
something but aboutness is a
relationship of something present to
something that's not present
something that's absent
um and this is one of the things I
realized that what was going on in this
move from Iconic and indexical to
symbolic to displaced reference is that
now there's no ABS there's no connection
we now have an absent relationship
there's no features that's in common
with the symbol and what it represents
to be clear when you say that it's
absent so again the word cat we can talk
about cat without there being a cat
okay that's right that's right and and
it still refers to them and in fact I
can say you know uh I'm gonna
gift you with a with a cat to adopt
um uh next week and and it will have
some consequences there'll be a real cat
um
is this the same as being hypothetical
or is hypothetical just a subset of what
you're referring to just one very
requires interpretation
there are
physical features in the world that can
afford it sometimes make it easier
so the fact that a photograph of a cat
or the shadow of a cat
um has features in common is an
affordance that if I'm sensitive to it I
can interpret it as being about it
referring to it pointing to it being an
index of it
um iconic and indexical relationships
are something physically affords that
interpretive process makes it easier for
us to interpret it
um because I already have information
about that correlation
by past experience I have information
about that covariance from past
experience so that when I see
um one of my favorite examples is wind
socks
wind socks are an in index of the
strength and direction of the wind
so they're an indicator
material feature I mean I I lots of
pictures I can show as well but we don't
have to go through that because what it
is is it's it's set up typically in
airports and heliports because you want
to know the direction and the strength
of the wind
um and a windsock is basically a conical
material object
um like like a flag in some respects but
it's got an open end on the con on the
point end of the con and the conical
part so that wind blows through it
um and it's on a rotatable
um structure so that um the wind will
blow it and uh
the straighter it is the harder the wind
has been blowing if it's not blowing so
hard the wind sock is sort of partially
extended
um and of course it's extended in a
particular direction so it's a great
device for showing uh the direction and
the strength of the Wind
um
why
even if you'd never seen a windsock
before and you're looking at it only
online
you would actually be able to interpret
what it's about why because you've had
the experience of looking at clothes
blowing in the wind of looking at leaves
blowing at the wind looking at your you
know your hat blowing off you know all
of these things and you have these
things to someone you look out at this
windsock even if you don't feel or have
any experience of the Wind
it has a lot of it brings to mind a lot
of like experiences iconic similar
experiences
but each of those experiences in your
memory is associated also with another
experience the experience of having wind
blowing
so when I'm out watching clothes blowing
in the wind or watching leaves blowing
in the wind
um I'm experiencing the wind so what I
see now looking at this windsock brings
to mind both similar sorts of things
in which a material which should be
hanging straight down is flopping around
hanging out
um that brings to mind these other
experiences which now are correlated
with not the same of as but correlated
with
um the experience that I've had of wind
now each of those correlations so each
of those images remembering the blowing
weeds the blowing clothes my hat blowing
off
um all of these features
um have that in common as well so
there's another likeness so each of
their correlations with wind
is a likeness as well a likeness between
wind experiences
so it allows us to look immediately at
this windsock
and say okay this is telling me that the
wind is blowing strongly from this
direction
because I have all those other
experiences but notice that they were
put together instantly probably within a
fraction of a second as you looked at
this for the first time
by virtue of the fact that it brought up
iconic
and indexical relations that built upon
each other to allow you to see this as a
conventional model of something it's the
iconic features in these are just in
your memory so what would this tell us
tells us is this is how perception is
building up this complicated causal
relationship that we see out there so to
see this hierarchy
this constructive hierarchy
began to bother me
and it bothered me in the following
sense
um in the study of life one of the
things that's been
really interesting in the last half
century is beginning to realize that
life as
Erwin Schrodinger suggested
is a process that's far from equilibrium
means it maintains itself far from
equilibrium
can you define that term far from
equilibrium so at equilibrium it's it's
where a system will fall to so to speak
degrade to
um if left alone that is what happens is
the system will fall to its lowest
energy State
um until it's prevented from falling
into a lower energy State
um
in in terms of entropy where we
oftentimes think about this
um a system that's well mixed
is at its lowest state it can't be more
mixed uh once you pour your
cream into your coffee and you stir it
well enough it's well mixed and it's
almost impossible to go backwards to
unmix it
um that's in its highest energy state so
room temperature mug would be at
equilibrium with the so room temperature
mug is now it's you might say that its
temperature the liquid is now the
temperature in the liquid is now well
mixed with its environment
so if it's at equilibrium that is
there's no shift it there's no asymmetry
between them
um the same thing is two of the coffee
in your mug that you've stirred
um what happens or the ink dropped into
water the stern becomes equally
distributed no part
um is significantly different than any
other part
uh whereas when the coffee is first hot
or when I first pour in the cream now
there's a separate gradient of
difference between the two parts that
gets eliminated over time that happens
spontaneously and this is the second law
of Thermodynamics of course played out
in different ways that is things go
towards equilibrium where gradients of
difference if they're not constrained
they will break down
those differences will dissipate over
time okay okay so the hot cup is far
from equilibrium with respect to a
colder room so why is the terminology
called far from equilibrium rather than
just saying not in equilibrium if for
example think about my refrigerator
my refrigerator does work to keep its
internal relationship far from
equilibrium with respect to the
environment
um we usually talk about far from
equilibrium as things being having
really high gradients and difference
so being away from equilibrium most of
thermodynamics was developed in what we
call mere equilibrium conditions
conditions where things are a little bit
off from equilibrium but will tend to
fall towards equilibrium
um by I say fall towards equilibrium is
that a precise term to be near
equilibrium versus far from equilibrium
or does it depend on the context well of
course it's it's it's near and far are
of course not not quantitative terms
so when we say near near equilibrium
we're dealing with a whole range of
processes in which the gradient of
difference is not huge
because when the gradient is is large
some very unusual things can happen
uh and this has produced a whole series
of studies that have really been going
on for more than a century now about
unusual features that happen far from
equilibrium
um uh so an example are shock waves
shock waves in which normally
differences in pressure
even out pretty pretty quickly winds and
difference in pressure in different
parts of the globe for example our
differences in pressure when you're you
know inflating a balloon uh and then
letting it sort of out
um these things dissipate pretty quickly
and easily
but you can push things so far
that the normal processes don't
dissipate that pressure so breaking the
sound barrier is a classic example
pressure can be moved from one part of a
of the air to another part of the air to
equilibrate the pressure pretty quickly
and easily it can do so
without much of a problem
up to the speed of sound
sounds that I'm producing now are the
result of pressure waves
that can be transmitted across
space in an atmosphere because of the
way the pressure waves
produce other pressure waves
and pass this along
um those sound waves are the result of
the fact that this this is how fast
pressure wave pressure differentials
move through the atmosphere so however
you can
because
the atoms in the in the air the
molecules in the air
um can only bump into each other so hard
so fast to move this
there are certain speeds above the speed
of sound we say that now breaks this so
you now can't actually have the pressure
dissipate across this boundary where
this pressure is so high that the air
can't disperse it fast enough
the result is when a jet breaks the
sound barrier
um it creates a break in the atmosphere
so to speak a boundary in which there's
high pressure air on one side low
pressure air on the other side and it
can't be relieved
it's only as the pressure decreases the
pressure differential decreases
some distance away from the jet
that suddenly it can release and it
releases in a huge bang a sonic boom and
this is because now finally we've come
back to the level at which that pressure
can be released and it's a huge
differential and it's released rapidly a
loud sound
um so what's happened here is that far
from equilibrium we've pushed it so far
that it can't re-equilibrate right away
and so beginning at the turn of the
century and particularly after the
mid-century last century
um studying systems that are very far
from equilibrium began to produce all
kinds of interesting results so we
noticed for example one of the things
that on the wings of jets
um as they're far from equilibrium also
they produce
um what amount to whirlpools
um vortices and the vortices are also
playing a role in in dispersing this
energy differential in different ways
and the vortices can actually mess up
your flight and one of the real problems
with breaking the sound barrier
initially was all the vortices that were
produced as you be as you approached
this
critical point
um really destabilized everything and so
there's a lot of shuddering you know in
the the first flights beyond the sound
barrier they were afraid it was going to
rip apart the jet
um turns out that it it's not enough to
do that and we find out how to go go
beyond that but but subsequently what we
discovered is that systems that we now
maintain far from equilibrium we don't
allow it to equilibrate can produce all
kinds of interesting effects and one of
the things that they do is they produce
orderly effects
now why do I say orderly
um
one of the one of the best examples of
this that everybody knows is a Whirlpool
we just talked about the vortices at the
end of uh of the wings of jets a
whirlpool in a stream
um what's happening is that you start
the water flowing down the stream
um and it comes and runs into say a a
barrier of some kind going around the
barrier
it produces all kinds of irregularity
lots of unstable
um behaviors
flow is no longer laminar it's now
broken up and and you get chaotic flows
but as the water continues the chaotic
flows begin to cancel out
um and whirlpools form
the whirlpool forms because all the
chaotic interactions
um are in a sense contrary to each other
because they're not all in the same
direction they begin to cancel each
other out
and so that over time all the
non-symmetric interactions begin to
cancel out and those are non-symmetric
are the only ones that are left and that
produces the laminar flow that becomes a
Whirlpool that actually allows water to
move through this
this barrier more efficiently uh and one
of the things we know about whirlpools
for example think about bathtubs being
drained and producing a Whirlpool the
whirlpool actually because it aligns the
movement of water molecules so they're
not in each other's way so to speak that
they're minimally out of each other's
way
it more effectively more efficiently
empties the bathtub the bathtub is of
course now a gradient of difference the
gravity that's pulling the water down
that gradient is being dissipated but
it's spontaneously because it's such a
high gradient it spontaneously forms
into a Whirlpool because it more rapidly
depletes that gradient the whirlpool by
virtue of allowing spontaneously
non-interacting non-contradicting
movements to be slowly eliminated now
empties the bathtub faster so if you
were sitting in the bathtub and then
just messing up the whirlpool constantly
um and now compare carrying that to a
bathtub in which you didn't do that
messing up the whirlpool would allow it
to drain more slowly
the whirlpool actually a system is far
from equilibrium like this
moves towards equilibrium by
regularizing the flow those are called
dissipative structures or dissipative
systems is there a difference between
those two what I'm saying is you're
dissipating the gradient in this case
right
uh but if you have a strong gradient
sometimes and particularly if that
gradient is maintained for a long period
of time like a full bathtub or a stream
that keeps running okay then what
happens is you're constantly dissipating
that gradient but the gradient doesn't
get dissipated right right right so
under those circumstances what happens
is it tends to fall into irregularity
because the regularity
reduces what you might call the
dissipation
length
how far a molecule has to travel before
it leaves okay if it has to if it
travels and it gets bumped back and it
travels and gets bumped back
by virtue of chaotic interactions it's
going to take longer to to leave and
that means the trajectory of its
departure say from the bathtub
um is longer it's going to take longer
take more time
so what happens in systems that are
maintained far from equilibrium is they
generally
develop interregularities
uh now here's here's the issue this is
why
way back in the 1940s the quantum
physicist Erwin Schrodinger said this
has got to be relevant to life
because life is maintained far from
equilibrium
because life is taking in fuel
to keep pumping it far from equilibrium
he had he talked about this as you know
as neg entropy you know if entropy is
the increase of this process he says
maybe they have to eat neg entropy that
food is like neg entropy pushing it I
think it's a bad term and most people
have abandoned it but the idea I think
is right and that is in order to stay
far from equilibrium because a system
that is far from equilibrium is dumping
energy as fast as it can
in order to stay far from equilibrium
you have to keep pumping up that
gradient
so the stream has to keep running
or maybe you have to heat something
constantly to keep it far from
equilibrium or like in your refrigerator
you have to keep a motor running that
dumps heat constantly because the
refrigerator is is spontaneously trying
to fall towards equilibrium
but you've got to do work
to constantly push it away from
equilibrium
to stay far from equilibrium you have to
do work
so that of course is relevant for life
and what happened since then and a lot
of systems thinking about life fell into
I think this error thinking that we're
just like a whirlpool
we're just like a very complicated
Whirlpool we get energy and we bump it
out and therefore our regularity is like
that
it turns out that that's a really useful
insight
because it says you know to be what we
are we have to do this
but it's incorrect it doesn't quite go
far enough
to generate all the regularities that we
have requires work
to generate
all the gradients different molecular
systems in our body all the different
cell types all the different molecular
interactions it requires constant work
and of course so it's you might say in
that respect it's like an extremely
complicated uh Whirlpool
um but in fact that's not quite the case
because the story with a Whirlpool or
all all far from equilibrium
physical systems
is that they're in the process of
destroying themselves
they're in the process of getting rid of
the gradient as fast as possible
they spontaneously regularize
in the process of dumping that gradient
as fast as possible
life has to be just the opposite of that
light hat life has to generate these
gradients and keep it
from undermining itself
self-organizing systems like this
are self-destructive by Nature
living systems are constantly involved
in trying to keep that from happening
so here's the Paradox a living system
has to use self-organizing like
processes dissipative processes
to generate the order it has
and yet it has to use those dissipative
processes
to keep those dissipative processes from
destroying themselves
that's a really interesting paradox
we've we're self-organizing but we're
using our self-organization to keep the
self-organization from falling apart
how could that possibly be or now when
we do it are you referring to a single
person or the entire environment no so
I'm actually talking about a single
organism I could be talking about a
bacterium okay just as well a bacterium
has to keep itself far from equilibrium
by taking in energy
using that energy to do work
to maintain itself far from equilibrium
in order to produce constraints in order
to produce gradients within itself
constraints on where particular
molecules are located and how they can
move and so on the bacterium has to do
this the bacterium has to use the second
law of thermodynamics
to maintain things far from equilibrium
it has to do work
two do something that produces it in the
opposite direction
to increase an entropy it has to
continually keep its entropy down what I
meant was in the case of a bacteria or
even a person is we dissipate something
so we're throwing something away but
what we're throwing away is
detrimental to us so what I mean is okay
so I thought that what you're saying is
it needs to get into a state where what
we throw away is then somehow useful for
us oh no no I didn't mean that I'm sorry
if I if I led you in that direction it's
my misunderstanding no that's all right
you know that words remember right right
oh so the the issue is that of course
we've taken energy and then we produce
waste
Heats if nothing else but obviously
waste products as well things that we
can't fully utilize or break down
um and we do that we're pumping energy
through the system in order to maintain
the constraints in this respect we're
sort of like a like a refrigerator
um it's I think it's a useful model
because we've got this this motor that's
constantly keeping the system far from
equilibrium by what by doing a lot of
work and generating a lot of heat
that's ironic because this device that's
supposed to keep something cool in the
process of keeping a certain region cool
it has to produce more heat
it produces more entropy than would be
given up than we'd be produced by just
allowing the refrigerator to go to
equilibrium
as the refrigerator we turn off the
motor the refrigerator now slowly goes
to equilibrium
entropy is increasing
that amount of entropy
um
is it a fixed amount of entropy
but by running the motor
we're now producing not only
the reversal of that keeping that
entropy from increasing but we're
generating heat in the process we're
also producing more entropy
so in fact that process of keeping
something far from equilibrium
um actually increases the total entropy
of the system
faster than just allowing it to go to
equilibrium so we have to produce waste
you know generating our societies we
dump a whole lot of waste into the world
a lot of heat into the world
um
it's because it's a it's an inefficient
process as we recognize but now let me
go back to the Paradox because this will
help us move to the next step the the
Paradox is
to do what we do
Now by we I mean all of us living
creatures
um including the bacterium to stay far
from the equilibrium in fact to stay so
far from equilibrium that we can
duplicate ourselves we can make more of
this stuff and actually reproduce
if you're doing a really good job of
staying far from equilibrium you're
pushing yourself away yeah yeah but but
the question is all processes that go
far from equilibrium are in the
processes of destroying themselves how
could it be
that that organisms don't do that so
Schrodinger has part of the story he
recognizes this problem
organisms are far from equilibrium his
his suspicion is that
the thing that we now call DNA that the
genetics is somehow providing
information and somehow the information
is keeping us from going far from
equilibrium
now
this is this is the interesting
connection because now it's it's giving
us a sense that although information
Theory which is itself described in
terms of a kind of entropy story
and physical entropy are also
interestingly linked together
every information system is a physical
system
every change of the information
signal that carries information
is actually a consequence of work done
on that signal
so that there's now information is not
just disembodied
information always is linked is always
grounded
but it's a grounded in interesting ways
like we described one two three
that grounding is also different ways of
being grounded you can be grounded in
form and you can be grounded in
physicality
so now so let's talk about the problem
of life then the origins of life
has to be a transition in which you use
which the living System is using this
process that's self-destructive
to keep the self-destructive processes
from being self-destructive
but it has to use them to do this how is
that even possible
and this is one of the things that I
struggled with and it turns out that it
also produces a one two three step
the one step being the second law of
thermodynamics
that is that entropy tends to increase
but if I have a system in which I'm
constantly pushing entropy against
itself constantly doing work on
something I can keep it far from
equilibrium
and that can produce something that the
increase of entropy wouldn't produce
that is now some regularity
some new constraints
the question is how can I keep that from
being self-destructive
it turns out the answer
is curious but simple
it has to be simple for two reasons
number one if life happens sort of
spontaneously by accident
somebody didn't make it happen
it probably had to happen pretty simply
it couldn't be really a lot of
complicated stuff happening
but the second thing is that this
transition had to be a transition
away from what every other part of the
universe is doing
that is tending towards increase of
entropy
and if it's far from equilibrium tending
towards even faster
living things have to prevent that hold
that off
for a period of time in terms of life on
Earth we've held it off for 3.8 billion
years at least
that's a that's incredible
when you think about it how does it work
but I realized is what has to happen is
that
self-organizing processes themselves
produce regularities
regularities are gradients or
differences or constraints
but there are different kinds of
constraints
one kind of constraint might be the
constraint on diffusion
in a liquid or diffusion of a liquid in
a liquid or molecules liquid or
dissolving diffusion the edges of the
cup
constrain the diffusion of heat a little
bit
the edges of the cup certainly constrain
the diffusion of molecules out of the
hot water into the atmosphere
um that's a kind of constraint
in this case I had to produce it by
producing a cup for example
but what I realized is that living
processes if they can be composed of
more than one kind of self-organizing
far from equilibrium process
might be able to produce constraints on
each other
reciprocal constraints
and the way to think about this is in
terms of what we would call boundary
conditions
that is a constraint is a boundary
condition like the edge of a cup as a
boundary condition Okay so
how does that work constraints can
produce boundary conditions or
constraints can be boundary conditions
and self-organized far from equilibrium
processes can't produce constraints and
therefore boundary conditions are there
chemical boundary conditions that can be
reciprocal of each other
and the ones that I hit upon
um turn out to be characteristic of all
of life
and they have to do with catalytic
processes
and diffusion processes so catalytic
process is when one molecule
decreases the threshold in which what
another molecule can either interact
with a third molecule or can break down
fall apart into two we call these
catalysts or enzymes they simply make it
possible okay it's also possible and
people have begun to focus on this as
maybe part of the story that you could
have reciprocal catalytic reactions or
Catalyst a breaks down some molecules to
produce Catalyst B which breaks down
some other molecules
and one of its products is catalyst a
this is a reciprocal catalytic process
um does that explode and become
exponential or are there conditions yes
it will literally be a uh you know like
like a nuclear reaction
it's it's a runaway process if Catalyst
a produces Catalyst B which produces
Catalyst a now you've got two Catalyst
A's which produce two Catalyst B's which
produce forces something has to be used
up but then that sounds to me like it's
dissipating itself it is totally
dissipated totally self-destructive
so when we set these things in motion
they use up the raw materials quickly
and the system now A and B diffuse away
from each other they can't affect each
other
the process stops and it stops faster
than if it was just a single Catalyst
because it's a runaway process
now there's another chemical process
that's important to this
and then we find so first of all we
we've noticed now when we look at the
chem the biochemistry of cells of all
cells of all types bacteria as well as
us
um catalytic Cycles are very very common
um we use that because to build the body
we want to have runaway-like processes
we want to produce more of stuff
constantly and you've got to run that
with energy
but of course these are dissipative
processes and self-destructive if we let
them go alone
what's the major limitation
on a reciprocal reciprocal catalytic
process it's that A and B have to be
near each other
they have to be in the same vicinity
when they use up enough of their raw
materials
their diffusion will take them away from
each other and a can't produce any more
B's and B can't produce any more A's
um diffusion is where it ends that is
the increase of entropies and you
increase more and more A's and B's
rapidly and rapidly and decrease the
substrate until finally there's not
enough substrate left and now the
process grinds to a halt it's reached
its highest energy
position but it's also produced lots
more of A's and B's
the process is diffusion
one of the other things that happens
spontaneously in the molecular world is
um
tessellation and crystallization I'm
sorry I just want to be clear so the
word diffusion here means a physical
distance between the two or the using up
of the raw materials or something or not
they're using up the raw materials slows
the Productions of A's and B's
A's and B's will spontaneously
move away from each other they mix
the second law of Thermodynamics says
that if you're not producing more of
them here they'll just tend to mix if
I'm not continually putting ink into
this place in the in in the water it
won't stay Bluer Than the Rest once I
stop the eight particles will diffuse
away well the same thing is true with
these molecules they'll spontaneously
diffuse away so as soon as
catalytic reaction slows down below a
certain point
now the constant the local concentration
of A's and B's will dissipate
so it's a dissipative structure
driven by first of all a far from
equilibrium relationship between the
substrates and how it's going to end up
but as soon as that is finished the
whole system dissipates and goes back to
its low highest energies highest entropy
State lowest energy state
the other molecular process that I
focused on
um was crystallization
and what we call tessellation molecules
that have a regular structure oftentimes
as they lose energy can link up with
each other and form crystals so for
example a solution that has a lot of
um
sugar molecules in it for example
heat it up and you stir and you dissolve
the sugar
once it cools down and the molecules
slow down and then our interaction sugar
molecules tend to stick to each other
and they Orient with respect to their
structure what you get is crystals
crystals form because the sugar
molecules are in a lower energy State
when they're all oriented with respect
to each other into a lattice-like
structure
this is also the way that cell membranes
in life and virus
shells form they form by virtue of
molecules that just tend to stick
together
okay and viruses it's it's typically
protein molecules that have a
three-dimensional structure that they
tend to stick to each other and they
form shells typically or sheets
okay it turns out that the formation of
sheets and containers by this process of
what we call self-assembly
when a system basically crystallizes
crystallization is another process that
spontaneously forms regular structures
by giving up energy
and as the
so think of your your solution of sugar
water cooling down
um as it cools down eventually
um the rate at which sugar molecules
attach to the Crystal and then get
dissolved off of the crystal becomes
equal runs to equilibrium
the crystal molecule will stop growing
at that State you won't get crystals any
larger
um
so what's happening is that
crystallization is also a process that
grows to a certain level
it's effectively Frozen in this level
because they're now stuck to each other
that's a low energy state but it can't
grow any further
so as crystallization grows
um it depletes its environment of its
raw materials
but now think about these two processes
they turn out to produce each other's
boundary conditions
in the following sense
as a crystalline structure grows in this
case I'm thinking of a polyhedron made
of a bunch of things that sort of grow
together into a shale
this is how viruses form for example
um at some point it will grow until it's
used up all of its raw materials
but what if you keep adding raw
materials then you can get to grow all
the way until it stops maybe closes
itself
the catalytic process is producing more
of A's and B's or A's B's and C's and
D's
um and a bunch of side products
breaking down
um some molecule into side products in
the process that liberates a little bit
of energy
but it's also producing a side product
that might be what we call a capsid-like
molecule a molecule that might be one of
those molecules that sticks together
and forms a sheet or a shell
now we have a situation in which in a
local region if a reciprocal catalytic
process produces enough molecules that
can form a shell
it will keep producing those every time
the shell begins to grow and decrease
the concentration of those molecules new
ones are produced into into that space
but now if the system grows into a
container a shell it will tend to con
contain the very catalysts that made it
possible
because the catalysts are going to be in
the same space
the shell is going to grow fastest or
the most where there's the most
catalytic reaction
and that means the system is gonna
capture all the features that are needed
to grow itself
but it's also going to stop the Catalyst
from diffusing away from each other when
they run out of substrates
so now you've got an inert structure
sort of like a virus it's got maybe a
protein shell and a bunch of protein
catalysts inside of it
but now if it gets broken again
and spews out its contents
the process will start over again
and now the catalytic process which is a
self-organizing process that would run
down if it wasn't stopped from diffusing
and the shell growing process which
would stop growing if it wasn't
continually getting new pieces to grow
larger and larger and larger
each of them is producing the boundary
conditions of the other
now you've got two self-organizing
processes that both support each other
and keep each other from running to the
end
so what what we see now is that
thermodynamic processes pushed far from
equilibrium produced self-organizing
processes
because it's a thermodynamic process
that's pushing something far from
equilibrium and then that system is
trying to give itself up it's a
relationship between two
second
law of processes two increase of entropy
processes one is you're driving
something far from equilibrium the other
is just trying to go back towards the
economy it's a relationship between two
second
the second law processes two entropy
increasing processes
um
what I've just described is that you can
also now have two reciprocal
self-organizing processes that stabilize
each other and and promote each other's
existence
that's what life has to have
life has to be able to figure out how is
two self-organizing processes can be
linked together so they each produce
some boundary conditions that allows
each other to happen but keeps the each
other from going towards full
equilibrium
so life has to be this interesting
coupling I've described this in terms of
a thermodynamic story which says that
we've got to expand thermodynamics
we've had to expand thermodynamics so
that we can talk about far from the
equilibrium thermodynamics that produce
things that produce regularities
transiently
um in order to produce regularities in
the world that can be useful but because
there's different kinds of regularities
different kinds of constraints it's
possible for those processes to become
coupled in such a way that they support
each other
that they that they do one thing that
that is not true in thermodynamics
so in our standard thermodynamic Theory
we have sort of the first law and the
second law the first law is that that
energy and matter can't be created or
destroyed now
depending on if we throw in nuclear
physics that becomes a little more
complicated so that mass energy is a is
a quantity that can't be created or
destroyed
um the second law says yes but entropy
will increase and order will
you know regularity and redundancy and
gradients will be decreased
um
what we have in life is something
interesting
because order can be created or
destroyed constraints can be created or
destroyed
regularities can be created or destroyed
but physical stuff can't be created or
destroyed it can just be transformed
when I say that a life of a bacterium or
of a person
can be created or destroyed
it's not because I'm saying that it's
material can be created or destroyed
its organization is what's there you and
I are not the same physical thing that
we were five years ago the material
stuff is Transit passed through we're
like a whirlpool in that sense
um but we're one that keeps ourselves
going
it keeps by virtue of this coupling
but now what you see is that by virtue
of coupling
these kinds of far from equilibrium
systems in this way
this is a system that protects its
organization
that reconstructs this organization that
repairs its organization if damaged
now
what we're saying now is the existence
of that organization
is being maintained
where matter and energy have this kind
of it's It's always it doesn't have to
do anything to stay in existence
organization has to constantly do work
to stay in existence
to stay far from equilibrium you have to
constantly do work and you have to do it
in such a way that you've balanced out
these relationships
so what this says is that
thermodynamics can be talked about in
three ways and I've I've coined three
terms probably won't survive history but
but it helps helps me think about them
the first one is like I call it home
Dynamics the second law of
Thermodynamics is about making things
more homogeneous over time
when we talk about equilibrium things
are getting more homogeneous so I I want
to call this homeodynamics
but when things are far from equilibrium
and producing regularities
um we want to say that that it's
producing forms in the Greek term for
form of course is morphe so I want to
call these morphodynamic processes
they're processes that die that produce
dynamical forms a Whirlpool is for
example a dynamical form
um it's material is passing through it
all the time but it maintains its form
it's a morphodynamic process the two
processes I just described the two
molecular processes are also Morpho
Dynamic processes one produces a
structure one produces a higher and
higher concentration of catalysts in a
local region
they produce constraints they produce
gradients
um but when they're coupled to each
other they also protect each other from
self-elimination
and they protect their Cooperative
relationship from self-aluma elimination
foreign
this is what life has to do
I call this teleodynamics because living
systems now don't just fall towards
disorder or go towards highest highest
entropy they go towards a Target
their target is self-maintenance in this
case
that Target has a specific form it's not
just general it's a specific
organization that's being maintained and
passed on so I use teleodynamics to talk
about teleology or indirectedness
things that have a specific end
also can go wrong there can be right or
wrong there can be good chemistry or bad
chemistry
self-organizing processes don't have
this
processes of simple entropy increase
simple chemistry so it doesn't have this
but if you have a process that maintains
its the existence of its own
organization
there now can be things that can go
right or wrong there are things of value
for it and things that are dangerous
so this is in a sense the introduction
of value into the world so does
sentience come about at the introduction
of values or is that separate yes
so another another way to say it is that
now we also have
information
about something
because the structure of this system
the structure of these device I I I call
these little units autogenic viruses
it's like a virus this has a virus shell
but it's not parasitic
it generates itself
so it's a structure that's got a protein
shell like a virus does and inside of it
it's got some enzymes some viruses have
even catalysts within them though mostly
they have RNA of DNA and that's because
they're parasitic they use the uh the
genetic systems of cells that they're
that are their hosts but
the argument I'm making is that there
could be something that's maybe a little
less than Life as We Know It
that has no RNA in DNA
but it can reproduce itself
it can repair itself if damaged
and therefore it'll be able to evolve
um
it's an autogenic virus because it's a
virus that is not parasitic but these
are systems that now
um
will have some environments that are
useful for it some environments that are
not useful
there are some chemical chemicals in the
environment that will be detrimental to
the process
um so it has value but it also
um
in effect is caring information about
itself
so it's got in its structure
even after that structure is damaged and
broken open
in the co-localization of all these
constraints
constraints embodied in chemistry now
information about what's necessary to
recapitulate that same organization
so that even if this system gets broken
open and catalysis begins again and
shell formation begins to form around
the catalysts
um during that process even though that
information
um was not information like a DNA
molecule or something like that it was
distributed in this distributed group of
constraints
so therefore those constraints
collectively
are about themselves
about their Unity about their coherence
about their integration how they need
each other
it's carrying that information forward
so that it can be embodied in new
chemistry
so the thing gets broken up and
dispersed
new chemistry begins to take place new
catalysis happens
New Shell formation happens
um over three or four Cycles like this
probably all of the chemistry is
replaced
just like in reproduction in organisms
but if all of the chemistry is replaced
then the only thing that's got any
continuity are the constraints
the constraints are of course these
redundant relationships these
correlation relationships and likeness
relationships
between these two processes
notice the similarity to everything I've
just been saying before this why did you
say it that there's a redundant
relationship uh
because you
processes has to produce multiple times
so to produce the shell you have to
produce more and more of these molecules
um and also now thinking about the
relationship for example between RNA and
DNA there are there are mirror images of
each other to some extent
they're complements to each other
they're like hand and gloves to each
other
but the two processes that I've
described are each the boundary
conditions for each other
they're they're in a sense of the like
their environments for each other
um in that respect there's a likeness in
the same way that DNA and RNA are in
likeness relationship to each other but
they're also then they have to be
correlated
physically Linked In Space
so they have both features they're
Linked In Space because they share a
common molecule
a molecule that's produced by the
catalysis that becomes a shell molecule
so you've got the likeness relationship
the complementary relationship between
the constraints that they each produce
one constraints diffusion the other
constraints the decrease in confusion of
diffusion of the molecules that produce
the shell as they produce
um complementary and therefore iconic
relationships to each other
and yet they have to be physically bound
to each other by virtue of sharing this
common molecule that produces a
structure in which the constraints
which are in a sense formal features
now can reproduce themselves in
different material
displacement
so what's happened to generate life
is the same relationship in which you
need
iconic relationships
linked to these indexical-like
relationships or covariance
relationships linked to correlation
relationships in such a way that they
produce this capacity
or displacement
now you can have information that gets
passed on
transmitted to another kind of molecule
and maintained my argument is that
that DNA and RNA are late developments
that begin to remember this kind of
stuff after life has begun
um
produce a better kind of memory and a
better kind of construction process but
that the same logic is involved all the
way down to the origins of life
and all the way up to the way brains
work
their constraints
in the same sense that mathematics has
constraints but they're constraints of
semiosis constraints of aboutness
you can't have a boutness without
certain things being constrained in
certain ways
um this is a quite General phenomenon
it's General enough that we can now
begin to say
um maybe this will lead us to new ways
to explore the origins of Life problem
and maybe it will lead us to new ways to
talk about the Consciousness problem
and that's where you want to go I know
when you ask me about sentience
because what what I'm now saying is that
even this simple autogenic virus
um
it's responsive to its environment in a
differential way some things it will
take in and other things it will not
take in
even in the simplest case
um if the environment is full of random
molecules but just enough of the
molecules to make catalysis and
self-assembly possible
the system will close and and capture
lots of diverse molecules
but only those that when it's broken
open will produce more catalysts and
more Shale molecules
will increase in numbers
and so over time the irrelevant
molecules will tend to be excluded
the system is spontaneously even in a
Mindless sort of way
organizing itself with its environment
taking in things which are useful
and expelling things which are not
useful
so what's the difference between
sentience and consciousness
say is called this Vegeta
analogy to to plants
plants are responsive to their
environment
um
the roots of plants
um follow certain nutrients and certain
water concentrations in the soil they're
sentient they change their growth
pattern with respect to that with
respect to sunlight plants move out of
the way of Shadows and into the sunlight
to maximize the amount of solar
radiation they're getting plants respond
to their environment we don't know we
don't think about it because they don't
move a lot but if we you know speed up
the camera we show in fast motion we can
see how sentient they actually are how
they're responsive to their environment
and some parasitic plants are even more
Insidious in their responsivity to their
environment I think about creeping vines
that that crawl up trees and and begin
to sap the nutrients out of trees and so
on they're not just sensitive to light
but they're sensitive to chemistry to
the shape of the tree and so on the
particular specific move it's just
slower hey they move that they're slower
but here's the issue
their relationship to what they
represent their aboutness is directly
linked to their chemistry
so it's the chemistry of
um the tree
as the branches are moving towards the
sunlight that's causing some cells to
expand in other cells to shrink that
causes that Branch to sort of Bend in
One Direction or another
um
that's a that's a direct chemical
reaction but it notice that it doesn't
have an independent relationship to
what's causing that relationship
it's a direct relationship to sunlight
or to water or to cold or whatever
the bacterium also has a direct chemical
relationship to its environment or would
an independent relationship look like
you and I just symbolic is there
something that's not possible every
every animal with a brain
what a brain does is it now
um doesn't just immediately react to the
environment
it reacts to structures in the
environment to forms into the
environment
um and then links those forms
to useful product processes in the body
so one thing you want to find out if
you're
um
a bacterium for example
I want to have some sensor that says
this is good to eat that's bad to eat go
towards the good to eat stuff okay
um
but if you have a brain
or with sensors you can now say Okay
um I don't need don't just need to know
whether this molecule fits with these
other molecules that I need
but I need to know things of that shape
have a lot of that molecule in them
so
brains are doing this displacement move
from the physiology
so brains are are now representing what
the physiology needs
but in a totally different way it's not
in terms of the chemistry
it's in terms of some other feature that
is correlated with the chemistry Maybe
but now we need a totally different
system to do this analysis it can't be
done by just just the chemistry it can't
be done by just the temperature gradient
or the heat gradient or the light
gradient what you want to do is you want
a system that can now take indirect
information from the world
and therefore use it to
get out the direct stuff that you need
so you need a whole system that in
effect is sort of like what we've just
been talking about but now at the level
of whole organisms
so what you need is to have some
displaced way of getting information
that's useful that's grounded down back
to your physiological needs the
chemistry of your body
so how does that happen well you got to
have the iconic and indexical jump that
we just talked about the one two three
step
but notice there's something else that's
interesting here
in one sense
even the autogenic virus has a kind of
self
it represents itself
and it represents itself again and again
in different materials why do you think
that is what we say about every living
thing is they have a self
itself reproduces itself repairs
itself modifies
the term self we use all the time when
we talk about living things
um and when things die they don't have a
self anymore
you know all their chemistry don't use
that term anymore
um self is about this Dynamics and yet
self is this fuzzy term
I think the problem with consciousness
is that we're trying to solve the
problem of self from this very high
level of brains oftentimes from the high
level of human brains when the problem
of self goes all the way down to the
origins of life
the problem of self was first created
in this very simple form
and itself was first created in that
form
until we understand how self comes into
the world in the first place
we're certainly not going to understand
how self Works in a complex brain
there's too much involved
it's displaced
away from what I call vegetative
sentience it's now a separate kind of
sentience I like to describe this as
subjective sentience
I think that you and I have an
additional one symbolic sentience
that makes us aware of things like
Infinity in galaxies and and truth and
so on that my dog and my cat are
uninterested in have no way of even
representing to themselves we're
sentience of that we're we're we feel it
we recognize it we can interpret it we
can talk about it we can interact with
it
creatures with brains that don't do
symbols can't do that so there's at
least three levels of sentience we want
to talk about here
and the quote the first question is so
how did the first level of sentience
develop that's what I was just talking
about okay that's an interesting
question we're gonna get there so my
first question was well how far does
that go so there was you said at least
three so then could you even imagine
four and if you did would that not just
be incorporated into three because
you're a human and you imagine that
someone else could imagine it like how
far does that go
what happens what's happening now in the
world with you and I
talking to each other
first of all symbols are not just in my
head
it's necessarily a distributed form of
communication
the representation that we're using now
to communicate
um requires not just one
if it's just me in the world I don't
need symbols
and in fact if it's just me in the world
I'll never develop symbols and I'll
never think about these other things
these will never be relevant
but symbols are not just in a human
brain
symbols are something that's distributed
around the world
it's a distributed form of cognition
what that means is that
I'm not just part of me and my local
group
but there's a little bit of Aristotle in
me
okay
uh not just not just here and now
and the fact that I can now communicate
to people in Australia at a moment's
notice
has changed that in a radical way
in one sense symbolic communication
has created the platform for a much
higher level form of communication we're
beginning to feel the experience
of what it's like to have this higher
order distributed communication that we
call the web
distort our politics our beliefs our
desires
the Dynamics of this larger symbolic
Network
are really becoming problematic
because there are certain iconic and
indexical relationships taking place
think about Facebook and how it
amplifies certain kinds of
likes not a surprise that they use that
term
um I like this it resonates with me
um why because of my particular
emotional state I'll pass that on to
somebody else now they have that that
icon as well
so one thing that happens is that human
emotions that tend to to have their own
um runaway process socially this kind of
mob technology that we're beginning to
create
has its own Dynamics
its own Dynamics because it's not in me
it's not in you and it's not in
anybody's control anymore one of the
reasons that this is a problem is we
don't understand how it does this
we're just beginning to understand how
it has these Troublesome consequences
you know why it's destroying a democracy
or two
um and that's because you know the logic
of how they set up the algorithm does
something in terms of symbols and even
pictures
even now icons and indices
um that also has a higher order iconic
and indexical and symbolic like
structure to it
it's got its own one two three repeat
and the the reciprocity the recursion of
it that is it changes the physicality
that made it possible
self undermining in many respects
and it may well be that the runaway
process will be so self-undermining that
it'll destroy stability of the of the
world community
we don't know whether it will or not so
actually understanding this logic
may not just be relevant to
understanding the origins of life may
not just be relevant to understanding
what a mind is may not just be relevant
to understanding what Consciousness is
I'll come back to that when I come back
to the sentient story but also is there
a kind of higher order sentience already
at work
that we're a part of that we're un aware
of that we can't experience but as
having an effect on us and our
experience in our very physicality
that's I think that the interesting and
worrying question behind all of this
to get at that let's go back to this
question of sentience
so the question of sentience is
one that gets us in trouble when we look
at Computing and we think well can AI be
sentient could it know something
um what I'd like to tell people about
Computing is that you know actually your
automobile engine
is a potential computer
how do you make it into a computer you
look at all of its various States
and you assign some interesting symbolic
value
a code to one of its states
and so that if each of its states has a
code value
when you run the machine you run your
car engine from State a to State B to
State C to State C D
um you're running it from symbol a
expression simple B risk what we're
doing with Computing is we're finding an
isomorphism between a mechanical
operation
um and a symbolic operation a
manipulation of tokens of manipulation
of science
that
the car engine doesn't know that it's
just an addition
any more than the calculator knows that
it's done addition
I've done the addition but I've
recognized that there's a regularity
a syntax to it a set of constraints
and those constraints can be
mirrored by a physical process that's so
constrained similarly constrained
the actual aboutness the interpretation
the awareness
is not in running the the algorithm
the algorithm is just a variant of a
machine this is why we call computers
virtual machines effectively
um
but now the difference let's look at
them even even in a simple example I
just described this autogenic virus
it's information the forms that it's
passing the constraints it's passing
from one step to another
embodied in the physicality of the
changes
it's embodied because it's embodied in
chemistry a process that's embodied in
chemistry
um
because it's about itself
because it's carrying information about
how to repair itself if damaged
or how to reproduce itself
in different material
it's also about its physicality
that is the information and the
physicality are not independent
oh
the form can be passed on the form can
go from generation to generation in this
process
with all the material changed but the
material has to be kept in that form
but you couldn't have passed on those
constraints if it wasn't always embodied
in some form some material
the information had to be physical
but in the case of this system in the
case of all life it's physical
embodiment of information about its own
physicality
that's an added twist
now remember when I said that
displacement
allows recursion
this is an interesting kind of recursion
this is a recursion in which a formal
relationship
has a recursive effect on its physical
embodiment
and therefore it's persistence or its
very existence
if it goes if it dies if it fails to
reproduce if it fails to repair itself
it goes out of existence
so this is basically a living system or
even a system as simple as this
autogenic virus
has information about its own existence
its information is about existence we
talk about information in philosophy we
use the phrase epistemology that's about
what we know what things are about what
things are known we talk about what
exists in the world we use the term
ontology
epistemology and ontology
yeah yeah epistemology and ontology is
sort of the two major divisions
um in metaphysics talking about what's
what how things are known or what
knowing means and what is
well here we're talking about what what
knowing is about the aboutness
is about its own existence it's the
epistemology of its own ontology
in philosophical terms that's what life
is about
so now let's jump up now I want to say
I've I've skipped a lot of levels
because we're going to go up to brains
and Minds real quickly but let's go back
to the classic problem the Mind Body
problem that Descartes introduces
he divides the world into the um res
cogitons
the thinking stuff
and the res extensa the extended
physical stuff in the world the physical
world and the mental world the Mind
world
and we might say the Consciousness world
um
and the phrase that everybody takes from
Descartes kajito ergosum
um I think therefore I am
um that's that's great for you and I
um Descartes assumed that thinking and
physicality were separate
um and that the only way they could
interact if they could was by some
special organ like the pineal body which
of course can't be true for a whole
variety of reasons but basically that's
because cognition thought
is not physical stuff
the aboutness the very Concepts that I'm
getting trying to get across here are
not physical stuff
to this abstract thing
so for Descartes the abstractness of
thought the abstractness of ideas
um with something really fundamentally
different than
material stuff energy
well here's the issue
he should have said not I think
therefore I am
but I feel
therefore I'm real
so let's go back now to this simple
pre-organism I've described
um
physically damaged it's physicality it's
been Disturbed
now the informational-like processes the
constraints that are there
begin to repair that specifically
in a sense it's the physicality of it
that activated the informational side of
it
to prepare the physicality of it
think about you and I
big jump here
um why
am I sensitive to certain things and not
other things
because they affect my materiality
they affect my physicality there may be
risky or helpful
the things that catch our attention are
the things that
either hurt surprise us
feel good
things that are really relevant
how My Body Works how I feel
I think that we've misunderstood
cognition cognition is tweaking feeling
and feeling is about our own physicality
it's this entanglement of the
informational part of our life
with the physicality part of our life
the in
separability of the two
that Descartes thought were separable
and couldn't come together again
that means that feeling
is a necessary part of representing the
world
and why representing the world is always
evolving towards doing it right doing it
better
getting truth getting reality
once you think if you think that
language and thought are just arbitrary
a lot of post-modernism sort of went
this way using language as a kind of
model
um maybe all of our physical theories
our theories of physics are just sort of
weird thoughts doesn't have anything to
do with reality
um no in fact just the opposite
because of the necessary entanglement
of semiosis that is producing aboutness
that it's always normative it's always
valuated
and it always feels like something
what we're doing feels like something
it's not just that there's information
here but where we're surprised or
confused or upset or worried
it affects our thinking
so let me ask you this
just like
off air
you reference that Universal grammar
should be capital u Universal grammar
because it's
right at the fundament when it comes to
physics
and chemistry
is
on one end the post-modernists and
perhaps post-structuralist though I
haven't studied them would say that it's
subjective but especially morality is
subjective
would you say that not only is it
objective in a sense it's capital O
objective
yes
it's O objective in the sense of of the
relation to a self
if there wasn't a self
or something
could be damaged or lost
if there wasn't some value there
could be no value to things in the world
it's objective
and subjective in that sense
but by subjective we want to expand to
even the simplest kind of self
that I've described
it's not subjective in the way you and I
are subjective but there's a subject
there
there's something that's subject to the
whims of the world
that will benefit or be harmed by what's
going on in the world
so in that respect it's not there in
chemistry and physics
chemical and physical processes that are
not alive don't have this feature
but it but in certain organizations of
chemical physical processes
it can emerge
there was a time before selves but now
theirselves there was a time before
normative features in the cosmos but now
there are normative features all with
respect to selves
so in one sense the ontology
epistemology story
has
Fallen prey to the Cartesian story
this dualism that we're never going to
get them together
my point is no
they actually are entangled they can't
be pulled apart
however you can have ontology without
epistemology
you can have chemistry and physics you
can have a big bang you can have an
early Universe without any sounds
but as soon as ourselves there's
aboutness
there's reference there's meaning and
there's value
and cells can become more complex we
happen to be an example of a very
complex form of Self in which there are
selves within selves to some extent each
of my cells is a self and has some self
my
physiology irrespective of my
Consciousness has a self in fact in a
coma with serious brain damage if enough
of my nervous system is working my
physiology is still going
in fact after I pass away and die my
fingers nails will keep growing my hair
will keep growing
because the cells are still alive
but the larger system is is no longer
there to support them and eventually it
will stop
brains and Minds ourselves within itself
in that respect part of my environment
is my body
and my body has an environment outside
of my body
so it's this nesting of cells but now
think about you and I go back to that
story about us being part of a global
symbolic system
linked together by language and
computing
are we like cells within that system
would we even know
that system
um would we know that it's influencing
us that it's modifying us the way our
nervous system modifies ourselves by
changing the flow of hormones and stuff
like that
um
I think understanding these principles
which
uh currently uh just anathema to
Material Science for some reason
current science either wants to say no
it's always already there it's always
just pan psychism every molecule has a
little psychological self-something to
it and therefore it's always already
there that's a non-explanation
to say that it doesn't exist and it's
all an illusion
is also a non-explanation because who's
having that illusion
and the illusion is normative
it's got a value Illusions are not real
but you gotta have something that can
assess reality and non-reality so that
the the Consciousness as illusion story
is also a reduction
um the Consciousness is already already
there in every atom every electron every
Quantum event
just simply postulates it into its
existence doesn't help us explain why a
whole lot of that stuff together in a
stream
and a small amount of it together in my
head
produce very very different kinds of
phenomena
to just say that that everything has
that doesn't it what it basically says
is no well even if that's true
the whole explanation of the difference
is in how they're differently organized
that's where all the explanation is
going to be it's not in that it's
already always always there yes yes
so we have to have an explanation
and what I've been trying to do here is
to say that you can go from basic
thermodynamics
build to life
and as soon as you do that
you have the semiotic capacity you have
this informational aboutness capacity
and with it you have purposes you have
aims you have ends you have self
you have aboutness you have value
and yet all of those things can become
much much more complex as you build
higher order kinds of self
so to wrap this up in let's say five
minutes because it's like a three hour
Behemoth podcast and I could keep going
for five more hours than I think you can
as well but let's wrap it up in
approximately five minutes with you
tying together some of the threads that
we've referenced but talk about absence
so your notion of absence which I don't
know if it's related to the Notions of
nothingness of the East but if it is
then you can talk about that it's not so
okay great okay so talk about absence
and it's relationship to purpose and the
other themes
well a purpose of course in our common
sense
understanding of it is is that
um there's something I want to happen
and I have a representation of it
typically
a mental image of what I want to happen
and I use that to organize my behavior
to make it come into into existence
that state of things
is currently absent
so before we got in this podcast we had
an idea of how we wanted it to happen
and what was necessary to get there
that was currently not in existence
but a representation of that which was
not in existence
was the target of this representation
was used to constrain my behaviors your
behaviors getting our computers together
looking at our watches doing all the
things that were necessary to make it
come into existence
so in that simple sense
my purpose
is something present the representation
in my mind
with respect to something absent that
was represented but is not present
so something present
linked
by my actions to something that's
currently absent which will then become
present
so that's a simple way to talk about
just sort of the Common Sense notion of
purpose
um it's asymmetric in time
in fact usually with respect to you and
I we have to do work to make it happen
because it's oftentimes that the world
won't go that way
the spontaneous way the world changes
is not towards that kind of thing I want
to happen
so usually I have to do work
this is true of course even for simple
microorganisms
they have a representation in a much
much simpler sense of course I would say
take again a bacterium
searching for for food
has a representation
captured in the form of its receptors
that picks up certain kinds of molecules
and then it has a way to assess
um gradients of these molecules
and it uses that
um
to basically accomplish something which
is to increase the concentration of
those molecules and therefore to
increase the food it needs to maintain
itself far from equilibrium
so in that sense there is a much simpler
sense of representation and purpose and
absence that is there's an absence of
enough food in this case
and an action based upon a
representation
though just a chemical representation in
this case
that allows that thing that's absent
being in an environment with low sugar
to being an environment with higher
sugar concentration
so in that respect purposive like
activity or what we might call
teleological activity and directed
activity
um is characteristic of this
relationship of something present
some vehicle some signed vehicle some
energetic or material something even if
it's just a process like a cognitive
active neurological process that's
continually recycling to keep this image
in mind while I'm engaging in some
activity
that's a physical something
that's representing representing
something that it's not
and this is that problem I began this
discussion with this displacement issue
how is something present
linked to something that's not present
therefore it's absent not nothingness
but something absent not now not here
now is this related to potentiality
versus actuality like that is to say in
that sentences these are potential
things but potential things you know are
not the only things that are absent
there's lots of impossible things
um that are absent as well yes
um and we can think about those things
because we've got this displaced way of
representing things
but so here's the issue what we want to
talk about is how in order for something
to be alive to have a self there has to
be self and non-self
there has to be
um
benefit
and harm
good for bad for truth falsity
um those things have to be there to be
alive
and that's because
um
what's being maintained what's being
brought into an existence is the process
of creating existence itself
so what's being maintained in existence
these forms these constraints these
signs
this information is being maintained in
existence it always has to be embodied
physically
and therefore only certain kinds of
physical processes can embody it and
then use it to interpret other physical
processes that are absent
so in this respect everything about
what I think
my thoughts are present in my head but
what they're about is not in my head and
it's not the neural activity going on
and it's not something necessarily even
in the world
it's absent in a fairly abstract sense
but it's because I've built up because
Evolution and my own development has
built up an interpretive system
that can use these steps
to allow
fully disconnected things
unrelated things to represent each other
that it's possible for something absent
something even impossible to be
represented
and in fact it's possible to now say oh
this is I would like
to create an autogenic virus in my
laboratory
these don't exist as far as I know in
science today
but I know all the parts I know how it
should work and I have a sense of what
kind of chemistry will make it happen
because I understand how viruses work
and I understand how catalysis works
um
this is something impossible it doesn't
exist Maybe
I actually to be honest with you I
suspect that that autogenic viruses
exist even on the earth we just haven't
haven't found them yet
um but assuming that they don't assuming
that they got wiped out went extinct or
whatever
um
I could have an image of what it would
be like I've just described this
they may not exist on the Earth
but because of this description
this thing which doesn't exist can be
brought into existence
for the first time
and it will have a kind of aboutness
that I don't have
that no other organism on Earth has
because it's a distinct kind of system
with a distant kind of aboutness a
distinct kind of relationship to its
World these things will emerge for the
first time in the world
in the same sense that I think that
selves emerged at one point in the
evolution of the cosmos probably not
just here but all over the place
um but they emerged at one time it was
possible
but it wasn't prefigured
I do think it was very very likely to
occur eventually as the universe cooled
and we got planets and we got low energy
Supply so I think particularly autogenic
virus-like structures I think are
probably going to be pretty widespread
in the cosmos for the simple reason that
they're chemically quite simple
and they don't don't have all this all
the sensitivity that living organisms do
Professor I just wanted to thank you so
much for spending such
being so generous with your time there
were I got to 10 of the questions and
some other themes I want to touch on
next time if you're willing to come on
for another round happy to do that great
is nurture versus nature and why that's
a false dichotomy and darwinian
evolution I said this in the
introduction so people were probably
looking forward to this but why
darwinian Evolution isn't the whole
story you reference this in one of your
talks and so I want to ask you about
that but we can do that next time I
talked about the other half as inverse
Darwinism
okay well we got to get to inverse
Darwinism next time and perhaps the the
topic of my new book great great Okay so
Professor again thank you so much
my pleasure it's been a great great
conversation I enjoyed it a lot the
podcast is now concluded thank you for
watching if you haven't subscribed or
clicked on that like button now would be
a great time to do so as each subscribe
and like helps YouTube push this content
to more people also I recently found out
that external links count plenty toward
the algorithm which means that when you
share on Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you